Okay.
Hello Alonzo. What is up, Joe? Good to see my brother, man.
It is so good to be back. I'm out. It's my first time seeing the new joint.
It's absolutely amazing. So I thought you'd been here the new spot, but no,
like I said, you were building this when I did the last one and this,
this when you said you could do everything here, it's like, yeah,
this is the bunker. I don't live that far from here. Come on.
So when the bomb hits, I'm like, yeah, I'm going to Joe's spot. Well,
if you live in the, if you're in the neighborhood, you want to use the gym,
it's always open. Thanks. Come on down. I'll bring canned goods.
Bring Water for fires. Yeah. If the shit hits the fan, Bernie had me nervous.
Bernie Sanders was just here. He had me nervous about climate change.
Whenever someone brings up climate change,
it's like a build that you didn't pay. Like Ah, fuck. Yeah, it's, it's real.
And, okay. So now I'm gonna do my first shameless plug for my new special,
when I use it out now, August 23rd on Amazon prime,
it's called the new wave of Amazon's because I'm very excited about them.
They're, they're testing the water so it's good to be in. So, uh,
it's called heavy lightweight and I call it that cause I do some heavy topics
and then I mix it in with lightweight shit.
Cause that's like if you do all heavy, like it's, it's wow. That was depressing.
Yeah. And you know, and I talk about the climate change thing, but it's like,
to be honest, like look, I'm a black man. 57 I got what?
Like 10 years left. I don't give a shit. You know what I'm saying?
Like statistically, God bless you. Millennials have wish you luck.
But I had a good run. So Nah, Nick's amazing for 50 cents.
Thank you. Yeah, don't crack it. Well,
and this is why I talk about right up until the day it does. Right. So like,
like literally, right till the day before I die. Look Great.
And then what happened? Some bitch died from what black been black.
His whole life shit just caught up with him. You got fucking diabetes,
sickle cell and high blood pressure and the same day
and wave of malady. But no, but the, the climate change thing is real.
But I think the big problem is it's slow. It's not dramatic.
So people, it's easy to, to not think about it because you know that, yeah,
the oceans rising, but it's an inch a year, which, you know,
I may not, that may not be exact, but you know what I mean? It's a lot, right?
So people don't, people don't see it with the urgency. And I,
and I think that's why you have the young congress pupil talking about it
because they're like, hey, this is going to be in our lifetime. Right?
But then you have the older generation where it's like, Eh, you know,
it's interesting. I'm pretty sure, and we should check this,
make sure this is correct.
And I think we learned about this from Randal Carlson,
that they increase CO2 to rates also increases vegetation because vegetation and
greenery, they use go use carbon dioxide, right? Yeah.
The increased rates actually this is like one of the greenest times ever.
Yeah. But
I wonder how does that offset versus the,
there's less land for these plants to grow on. You know what I mean? Like,
so when you look at like rain forest jungles being with like that like is the
opposite of that was they say that it's makes it harder for them to grow. When,
what article says that? Uh,
is there any articles that say that's not the case because it seems like that's
not something Randall would lie about. He was talking about how um,
this is like one of the most, uh,
green times ever in the increase of forest and in green trees.
I guess I'm seeing both of them then.
So the very first things that pop up are high carbon levels,
make it harder for plants to grow from ThinkProgress. Second thing,
increased carbon dioxide levels and air restrict plants ability to absorb
nutrients from science. Dot. G. Dot. Se to another country. I think Sweden,
yes. About think progress. Sounds like a bunch of fucking hippies.
Bunch of tree hugging mission. NASA says though, it's making a greener for now.
Yes. So I would buy that. The thing about that thing, and this,
it didn't this funny like with science you have to check because you have to see
if there's a political agenda.
NASA one you have to see if there's a political agenda behind the science,
right? Yeah, for sure. But with NASA,
I'd go with what NASA says. I think there they say go, scroll back up please.
Uh, CO2 is making the earth greener for now and then says, uh,
a quarter to half of earth vegetated lands have shown significant greening over
the last 35 years,
largely due to rising levels of levels of atmospheric carbon dioxide.
According to a new study published in the Journal for Natural Climate Change on
April 25th. Yeah.
See an international team with 32 offer authors from 24 institutions in eight
countries led the effort,
which involved using satellite data from NASA's moderate Resolution Imaging
Spectrometer and the National Oceanic and atmospheric administration's advanced,
very high resolution radio,
radio meter instruments to help determine the leaf area index or the amount of
leaf cover over the planet's vegetated regions.
The greening represents an increase in leaves on plants and trees equivalent in
areas to two times that continental United States, Blah-blah-blah.
So Randall's right, I think, but I think, uh, either way we're fucked.
And then on top of that, we'll just be, we'll all die in a very green planet.
How much, if everything melts, if the polarized caps mount, like,
where could we, can we live in South Dakota or some shit? I don't know.
I don't think so. Make it in. I, I don't keep inside, you know,
I don't think so. Like, like, uh, you know,
they want California to fall into the ocean. Right. You always hear that Texas.
It's like, yeah. And the title wave will kill you. Yeah. You know what I mean?
I don't know. Um,
I don't think that safe because it would be such a drastic, I mean, right,
so much
of the earth's weather is controlled by the polarized caps,
the magnetic poles, the, the rainfall, you know,
glaciers and it's all interconnected. Right?
That's why the hurricanes are getting stronger, right? Yeah.
So if you lose like the oceans controlled Earth's climate because the Wa,
you know, having to do with evaporation and so on. So anyway,
for sure you shouldn't be getting weather information from you or me.
Listen, we got to two experts, scientists here. We've been,
we've been talking about this for minutes and they get better for hours.
All totaled over our lives. But no, it, it's um,
it's real. Yeah. But it, but it is something,
I think it's definitely younger people are going to be more interested because
it could be a major thing.
Like if you're 30 now when you're 60,
this could be a real, real big issue.
It's a bad time to buy real estate in Miami. No, you don't want, you know,
when is a good time to buy real estate? A lot of coconut
and you'll get a party if found out you have stage four cancer,
but you do have a large bag that, you know,
I love that you mentioned that because this is been a thing.
So the the weed industry be illegal, right?
And they say there's all this money that people can't figure out what to do
with, right. The banks don't want it. Like Miami was built with cocaine money.
What happened to those money laundering guys who cleaned up all of that money,
built all that real estate. Like where are they now? Different era.
I can't believe that there's not people out there who can figure out how to
clean this weed money and boost the economy. They will be able to figure it out.
But it's going to take a long time.
And the people that are trying to figure it out right now, like the,
the weed dealers that are selling it legally,
but then have all the stockpiles of cash, they've got their halftime,
they hire hire mercenaries and they hire blackwater guys. And Shit.
The fucking special ops guys to watch their money, they really have to. Um,
my old, uh, Condo I rented out, right.
So I was renting to a guy, his business was,
he handled the credit card transactions for the weed places for the dispensary's
and stuff. And you know, the bank shut him down and this,
and he didn't pay the rent late. And I was like,
I got the only guy in the weed business who can't make money like I'm renting
to, there's one guy in weed who can't. I was like, listen man, I take cash.
Just pay the rent. Like, like how can you,
everybody's buying it, selling weed on credit cards and you can't pay your rent.
How did I end up with this gun loser?
People are flying here to get some weed. Yeah. They tour,
they tour tourism and my guy, nothing, you know,
really took it on the fucking Chin is Amsterdam.
Remember when people are talking about going to Amsterdam,
let's go to HIMSS dam to get high. Yeah. They can get high here. Stupid. Right?
Nobody's [inaudible] windows though. That's true. They still got that.
That's true, but been there before you, if you could just see the line of,
if you see a video montage of all the guys coming into this school, you're like,
oh, oh, oh just over the last couple of weeks.
Joe just ruined Amsterdam tourism. Yeah. Amsterdam tourist board is like,
why is he picking on us? What did we do? Well they have good fights over there,
but they fucked up when they made mushrooms illegal. They, they,
they stopped people from selling mushrooms and the cafes.
Now is that because it is, why would they do,
I don't understand why they would do that cause I was wanting to say it's doors
they can regulate, but no, it's dorks go over there and blow their brains out.
They eat too many mushrooms and freak out and try to jump in the river and you
know, that's what it is. It's dorks. It's always dorks. They ruin everything.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, it's one of those, it's weird.
It's weird to me cause it's like, listen,
if you can hit get a handle on your drug tourism, you know, just don't do it.
But I don't know. It can be done correctly.
I think if you want to do drug tours and correctly, first of all,
you need to check people, make sure they're okay,
find out what kind of medication they are and like do a blood test on them.
Find out what kind of medication. Oh look, you're on SSRI.
He didn't even tell us, hey stupid, you're not supposed to take this stuff.
This is gonna fuck you up next. You know, and, and really, really test them.
Then, you know,
find out about their psychological history and start them off with a nice light
dose today. Today's Tuesday, today we're going to give a nice light dose,
like a half a gram. We're just going to say that you react. That would be it.
Just, just, you know, this is how much you get in. See how you react.
Exactly. And then, then come back on Wednesday. Right?
You think about it for 24 hours.
You come back on Wednesday and Wednesday we're going to give you two grams.
Yeah. And then we go, got to cut you off. Yeah.
And then you come back on Saturday and you get that five grand.
Oh
yeah. Just do it right with doctors nearby and ivs filled with vitamins.
I'm sure that's why they don't because who's going to pay for all of that part
to works, you know, the same door
they would pay if you had like a,
if you could save up your money and have like a real safe mushroom trip,
like a legit safe mushroom trip at a medical institution where they've got
everything locked down and everybody's safe and the mushrooms are safe and yeah,
people would pay a few hundred bucks for that.
But I haven't done mushrooms but would that, no, you want to try it? No, no.
Thanks man. I'm retired man. You know that from everything. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. We talked about this like when did you retire? Uh, 88 oh yeah.
That's crazy. Yeah. I mean, you know, itch. No, no, I, you know,
I've been high enough that I don't feel like I'm missing anything.
So when you talk about it, it's like fascinating to me. But then,
but then there's also that case of like, now, like I don't want to be that high,
you know what I mean? But, and again, I don't knock what anyone else does,
but this is what I wanted to ask you.
If you did it under those medically supervised conditions,
would it still be as much fun? Yeah. It's fun no matter what.
As long as they leave you alone while you're tripping. Yeah.
Long as they don't bother you, you know? Okay. I mean, I, like I say,
I have no idea. I have no frame of reference, so I can't say like,
that would be, you know, not be cool or whatever. I don't know.
Fuck with CBD at all now and good for you and it doesn't get you high. Yeah,
I know. And I don't, again, I don't knock it.
I don't necessarily have a reason to fuck with CBD.
I'm not in like any kind of pain or anything like that or any, you know, uh,
but I don't knock it as a treatment.
I know it does work and there's benefits to it.
It's just not something you need that I need or that I do, you know? Um,
it's like the knees, right? The need, my knees are kinda trashed,
but when I work out and stretch and warm them up, they're not, it's not bad.
And I've talked to doctor and doctor like, yeah,
eventually we're going to do a knee replacement, but you don't need it now.
What's going on with your knees? Arthritis. Just, you know,
you don't have to do a knee replacement. Yeah. Stem, stem cells,
which is something I may do. I know,
I've heard you talk about it and that might be the way it, a matter of fact,
I have a friend, um, and she's like in her,
she's around 80 and she said, yeah, that's what they did for her knee.
They did stem.
So my mom had her knees replaced before she passed away and she said, yeah,
that's one of the things you inherited from us. Bad knees. It's like in the fan.
I was like, thank you. But, but she also made me funny,
so I couldn't really be mad at her. She had great. And I was like, all right,
I'll take the funny and the bad knees I had the bad knees are workable. Yeah,
I'm telling you it CBD first of all is going to help that because it reduces
the, all the symptoms of arthritis. Like Day Foley, he,
his hands were fucked up. He had like some severe arthritis in his hands.
CBD completely cured it. He crew straightened his hands out.
His hands were always at like a slight bend and now,
now he's got a full range of motion in his hands. He's blown away by it. Yeah.
My knee problem is impact, you know, just ball or basketball. Basketball. Yeah.
So even [inaudible] and all that stuff, that's all trashed. So even now,
like I can do most, like I can't jump, you know, I can run, I can do.
So I did this crossfit,
I tried crossfit and my knee swole up and I went to my doctor. If he's like,
cross, what the Hell is wrong? You jumping up on boxes. My, my,
uh, my doctor's diagnosis for 90% of my problems. You're old.
Don't do that, man. You can,
you can fix a lot of those problems with stem cells. A lot of those problems.
Yeah, it regenerates tissue, reduces inflammation.
It does a lot of amazing stuff now. And I haven't researched this at all.
I mean, you know, I've heard stuff up. My, my stem cell knowledge
is about equal to my climate change.
Well mine is slightly better cause I've, I've actually had a bunch done on me.
Well this is what I wanted to ask you about.
So I know when you talked about it early on, you went overseas, right?
You left the no, no, you did get it done here.
So that was my question because I've heard people talking about going to Panama,
Panama and Asia, et Cetera, that you don't think you want to go to Asia. Yeah,
they're doing over there. But Dr Riordan,
who's the guy who treated Mel Gibson and Mel Gibson's Dad,
he actually treated my mom. My mom was in risk of a knee replacement. You know,
she's in pretty, you know, pretty bad pain and the doctor's like,
you got to get a knee replacement. I'm like, okay,
maybe you have to get a knee replacement. I go, but before you do that,
let's send you to Panama. And they'll,
they'll do this full three day stem cell procedure. They use ivy stem cells.
They, they, they blast the area over three different days.
They hit it with stem cells and you know,
my mom is 73 so it was a while before it worked.
She, you know, for the first four months she was a little discouraged. She like,
I don't feel anything different and I don't know if this is working.
And then somewhere around five, six months,
she started feeling a lack of pain and the pain just start stopped.
It just stopped being like a part of her daily life.
And then now she could walk and it's not bothering her. She goes,
I'm walking with no pain. I can walk up hills with no pain. And she goes,
I want to do it again. So I was like, fuck that. Let's send you down again.
So she's, she's headed down again to get more of it. But you did it here. Yeah,
I did it here. Well, I think, no. Is there a difference? Yes, they can.
They can go ham in Panama, they go ham,
they just fucking it fill you up. They just bring a fucking bucket of stem.
Sorry, big ass needle. There's,
they don't have the same regulations that they do in America,
so they can get away with a lot of different stuff. And Dr Riordan,
who is one of the pioneers of this and he's written multiple papers and he has,
uh, you know, scientific journals all about the benefits of stem cells.
And it's particularly effective on people with neurological conditions,
people with neurodegenerative diseases of like,
and he's written extensively about all that stuff. But when he came on, I mean,
he,
he blew me away and I had already had some success with stem cells in America
where like,
I had a full length rotator cuff tear in my shoulder and they, uh,
injected it with exosomes,
which is like the most advanced form of stem. So they used to,
there was the ways they used to think is stem cells.
They felt like when you put stem cells into an injury,
that the stem cells were re proliferating this area with new tissue,
but now they think that the stem cells,
I'm sure I'm butchering butchering this if you're a scientist now,
I think they think that the stem cells are releasing exosomes and that the
access songs are actually with does it,
so now they just go straight to access homes and then they inject
exosomes into these particular areas.
Now they have another product called Wharton's jelly that's even more potent
than I, I just got shot into me. My name is Sam. I get an injured man.
I just fucking head on down. I'm like,
what's the purpose of having money if I'm not fucking shooting myself up?
You go juicy stem cells. Here you go. But it works. If I got stem cell cash,
I probably do. You do that, but it's not that. Yeah, you're successful. I'm no,
I do medium list, like an Amazon special. No, I do Alonzo, but listen,
I do all right. I tell people I do. I don't make as much as they think,
but I do. All right. You know what I mean? Kids?
Cause like when people see you on something they like,
oh well you got $10 million. Like, no I don't. I'd like to, but I don't.
But uh, but yeah, so, okay, well we'll talk about that then we'll talk about,
I was on special, my push the top. I hope so. You know it, I mean, you know me,
I've been in the Biz forever. I loved the Biz. I loved the, I loved the,
I appreciate the love you give me on the podcast.
People always tell me when you are some gift. Oh yeah man,
they were talking about you. You know, and I, and I appreciate that. Right. Um,
krs one said long time ago, respect will outlast cash, you know,
so I appreciate that and I appreciate you too, man. But, um, yeah,
it'd be nice to have something blow up like that, right?
I think you can so many times that it happens in careers. So, uh,
well they're doing a lot of specials now. They got, Gaffigan is doing Amazon,
a Russell Peters doing an Amazon. You, who else?
Someone Jimmy o Yang's got one. Yes,
coming up Amazon theme man, why does he have an Amazon?
But there's a lot of like really funny people that are doing it and as long as
they put the money into promotion and let people know, I mean they're,
they're doing great right now with the Marvelous Mrs Maizel.
They have a lot of new Amazon prime series like that.
Fleabag is supposed to be hilarious.
They have a lot of good series that they're promoting that people are really
getting into. And if you have Amazon prime, like if you order shit with Amazon,
you get free, you get free Amazon TV, TV. Yeah. People don't even know that.
I know. I know. And it's good. Yeah. Amazon is legit. Good.
Super. Yeah. So I'm rooting for them 100% yeah. And there's,
you know, look, Netflix has almost,
I mean they've got the market kind of cornered until Amazon came along cause
nobody wanted to do in Montgomery central anymore. Comedy central is great.
It's better than no special, but it airs once.
That's the problem with comedy central years once and then it's not in this day
and age, man. I think a, I think HBO is still the Big One, you know,
as far as television. Yeah. Television. Yeah. As far as the TV, one hour like h,
but showtime was good to me. Show time. Um, put on a couple of specials.
We'll show time made Sebastian oh, big guns made. Sebastian,
he just clicked with [inaudible] with the width. And it's,
it's funny how that happens cause you really can't say why. Yeah.
You know that certain ones do. And that's no disrespect to Sebastian.
It's just, yeah, certain things take off and others don't. And it's like, well,
I mean it was really good. I mean, oh yeah. No. Like I say,
no disrespect to them. No Sebastian, he's a great comic. He's, he's been round,
he's worked, you know what I mean? It's not like he just fell out of the sky,
got a special and didn't have anything behind it. Now the guy's a comic.
He's real for him. Who? Well, you know who blew off on showtime? Gallagher.
He might be the last guy that blew up on showtime before Sebastian. Right.
I mean, he's stop and think about it. Yeah. When, who the fuck else?
It's like Sebastian and Gallagher is the guys who blew up on showtime.
Let me think who else. Yeah, that's a comedy wise.
Dana Gould had a special on showtime. Who else? What should they did?
Showtime did a few, like a Billy Gardell had the new comics thing he did.
He tried to break some new comics on that Rodney Dangerfield type deal.
And um, but yeah, you're right. Yeah. But again,
that's where, that's where our business, like this business is fickle, right?
Cause they're always trying to figure out, you know, why is this a viral video?
You know what I mean? Like, like man, that squirrel got more views.
We spent $8 million producing this series and that squirrel got more views than
we, you know, and it's like, why?
Yeah.
If you're just trying to concentrate on making things viral and you will go
fucking crazy. Yeah. You can't figure out, you know, why people are,
are connect to this one thing and even though others have done it or done
something similar or whatever, and then yeah,
it's a tricky fucking business. And then how about youtube?
Like Russell Peters blew up because of Youtube. Absolutely.
Worldwide. Boom, boom. Unbelief. And you know people,
and it's funny cause people here,
they don't realize how famous Russell is because he's not that famous.
He's not as famous here now he can hang out over here,
he'd go places and he lives here. It's like got the best of both worlds.
Cause that mother fucker sold out the o two arena, two nights in a run.
I know that's like 20,000 plus people. You know who's like that? Uh,
Jimmy Carr, you know, general shore. Yeah. He's hilarious. Yeah.
Jimmy's hilarious. And like internationally, Jimmy is a monster.
Unbelievable. But here like they check his id, you know,
like he pull out the black card and they'd be like, let me see your Id.
Yeah. I mean he does the roast, uh, those roadshows shows over here.
Yeah. And stuff along those lines. But yeah, he doesn't have Neal,
but he's working here more often. He's developing. He,
I saw him in Montreal and he said, yeah,
he's developing his audience in a state.
So now he's doing like small theaters here. He says,
obviously if he goes anywhere where people from the UK are like,
so when he's in a big city and there's a lot of Brits,
then he can sell out like New York or Boston or something like that. Yeah,
he's a great writer. Oh Man, that guy's funny. Sharp. Just, yeah. And so,
so British like so dry and completely inappropriate. Yes.
You know, that's what I love about him. We do in, in Montreal,
we do this a benefit show for hope and cope and it's like a, a,
um, rehab medical facility. You know,
there's some cancer patients in there and people other and,
and Jimmy just opens like, yeah, I've got to hurry up and don't have much time.
Well, I have time.
I was just [inaudible] Joe. And they loved it. They, they just,
they fell out, you know, and he's, he's like, uh, any of you here last year now?
Probably not. Anyway, at this point,
most comics go to Montreal to hang out with other comics. Oh, absolutely.
We call it summer camp man. You see your, you know, yeah.
You see friends and like I see him there every summer and then you see people
who you just don't see or don't bump into, you know,
regularly and your regular whatever and you get to hang out.
And then there's always new people you meet.
Like this year I met Nick Kroll who was cool. He's grand a, you know,
cause I liked big mouth. It is a cartoon. And um,
Pete Holmes and Pete Holmes was hilarious cause he was doing this thing at the
roasts called mean Pete. So he was doing like a completely different cat kids.
You know, Pete Holmes, a nice guy.
And he was at the roast just destroying people and he just kept yelling at me
and Pete, you know, so, but, but yeah, so that kind of stuff. Yeah,
it's fun man. It just to a forever meeting. Well that was the first time,
I don't know if you remember, I definitely wrote,
it's the first time you and me hung out. When was that? Yeah, it was,
it was him or old. Yeah. So it was 99.
It was my second time in Montreal. Right. I'm doing comedy.
I don't know about six years. So I'm still like new, like I buck.
But I knew you from the um,
from laugh factory in from around town and you were hanging out with Kevin James
and I think he had just got his show or just finished his first year of his show
or whatever. And you were like, come on.
And I jumped in a cab and we went around doing spots and I'm like,
and you would be, you'd already been on news radio and I, and I'm like fuck,
I'm hanging out with Joe and kept like we're doing spots like you.
You know what I mean? Like as a new comic, you're like Holy Shit,
just the coolest shit cause cause I,
I could get in cause I got out the cab with youtube. So they're like, yeah,
yeah, you can do five. So that I remember, I still remember that. That was fun.
But that's what Montreal is. So now I'm that guy right now I,
I've been to Montreal so much.
I got people calling me in La asking me about Montreal left.
They told us to call you.
I had Chris Spencer calling me to get spots on shows and I was like, Chris,
I don't book it. He's like, yeah, but you know, you know,
and then I was able to get him a spot, I guess. I do know, I guess it works.
Yeah. But the problem is that you get into, if it works, once you know,
then you're the guy they call. Yeah, that's a, listen,
if you're listening to this podcast, no, I can't help you.
Did they still have a bunch of different venues?
We can drive around and get spots? Not none, not as much.
Everything's booked now. You know,
you know the big difference now there's a lot more TV.
Like remember back then there were like two or three people had hours, you know,
not men. Now there's like a whole series of one hours that they're taping.
And then um, you know,
like Kevin Hart did the whole lol thing there for a couple of years.
So he was taping all of that. So there's a lot more.
TV is more involved. This year there wasn't a whole lot of Netflix.
The last two years there was a ton of Netflix and Netflix was doing a bunch of
half hours and stuff. They were filming them at the festival.
So it's weird to me. It seems like the festivals supposed to be fun.
It's not supposed to like film us. I think it's still fun in that,
like you said, you see other comics and you get to hang out,
but there's um, there's not the,
the development business that they're used to be right. That's not there.
But the content business is there and they figure like,
we got all these comics in one place,
we'll set up cameras and we'll shoot bang, Bang, Bang, Bang.
I think that's so, so there's less of the,
there's still some shows where you could just, you know,
jump on and it's friends of whoever and the midnight shows, they still do that.
They have like a whole midnight when they could midnight surprise or whatever.
You don't even know who's on the show. And that day they call people like, Hey,
you want to do a spot? And they still have the nasty shelf. They still do.
Nasty show is still huge. They do.
They do the ethnic show now remember they used to be, that's what they call it.
Well they used to be like the wise guys was the Italian show. Right.
And then they had the Jewish show and then they had the uptown was a black show
and this and that.
Well now they've combined all of that and they call it the ethnic show and they
have built,
so there'll be just different comics on there from different ethnic groups.
I've hosted it a couple of times.
It's a lot of fun actually to do ethnic material. No,
some you do some, some people do some, some don't. I think my favorite one,
one year I was hosting it, Nadelman was on it. Dan Adelman,
who you know [inaudible] he hilarious guy and he was like, yeah, ethnic. Yeah,
I'm a Jewish comic from New York. That's such a rare find.
Ethnic is a weird word to mean, isn't everybody ethnic? Yeah, but,
but it's there, you know, it's the right title for catchall.
And also the other big thing is Canada. It's not as,
they're not as hung up on it. Right.
So you're not as worried about being politically correct or,
or hurting someone's feel. You know what I mean? Like they understand, yeah,
this is a comedy festival and people are gonna say shit that is inappropriate
and, and do, and, and being friends, you know,
can't we make fun of each other? Right. And it's so, yes.
So your ethnic group may come into it,
but not from a point of racism or hatred or judgment. Just,
it's fucking funny that we're the same or different in our ethnicity or in our
background and weaken. We joke about it.
Does a comedy works exist anymore up there when undirect unfortunately to works
went under, um, Jimbo take off. Yeah. Vanish somewhere.
I don't know what happened to Jimbo. I don't know.
I'm not sure what happened to him, but it was great. That club was,
that was the epitome of comedy, right? Yeah. You go upstairs,
there's 150 people in a 120 seat room isn't even that many.
It was 120 seats and, and the Fire Marshall would've shut it down every night.
Right. Cause if there was a fire in comedy works,
it would've been a horrible tragedy. And you know, but,
but the energy was like, you get on that stage and just kill and you know,
it's like, yeah, we got the Gallo over here,
we got 3000 seats in the most beautiful theater you can imagine.
But you really want to see the, you really want to have fun. Go upstairs.
The comedy works in sweat.
You're literally sweating for 15 minutes because there's no air conditioning.
It was terrible. Worked heat rises. So we should put this place upstairs.
Well,
when they wanted to stay warm in the winter and they have like a little comedy
scene, like a local scene. Yeah. And they still have,
they still have some places. Like there was one I was working,
I can't remember the name of it, but it was the same kind of vibe.
It was like an upstairs bar that they converted for the, for the festival.
They put in a hundred chairs and you, you know,
and it was great and that's where they were doing midnight surprise. So that,
that venue is still really cool. And then they had the theater Saint Catherine,
which is like this small stage in a long room. Yeah, I did that one man,
that, that one still has, you know, so,
so there are still some places that have that funky comedy vibe.
I mean, you know, but that comedy works room as it still there.
Could somebody like turn? I don't know. I have no idea if it's,
if it's there up, it's been redeveloped but yet works was,
that was the shit that was the great, that was the fun room.
That was where you ran your set before you do your, you know,
Gallo or TV taping or whatever and it would just kill cracklin those,
the first time I ever saw Lenny Shoultz give us he crazy wedding, you know,
crazy Lenny. No, he was a hilarious guy. That was right when I was coming up.
He was just at the end of his run and of his career and he says wild,
crazy old man who would bring props on stage.
Attitude was like so fun. Just a maniac.
Like he w he would pull up a a s you know a smokey the bear doll and he's like,
only you can prevent forest fires. And he just yells,
fuck you punches his bear the face. It didn't make sense.
And I'm papers though. So stupid. You're fucking holding your body.
You couldn't even stop laughing. My, my favorite random funny thing like that,
there's a guy still touring as far as I know in Canada called Mel silverback
ever hear melts, silverback belts, silverback half Jew,
half silver back mountain gorilla.
And he would wear the Tuxedo with the big ruffled shirt like the old Catskills
comics and he wore gorilla hands and a gorilla head. I'm telling you.
And he would these old Catskills Thai style jokes,
that gorilla mask. Oh man, Joe, we, we,
he auditioned for last comic when I was a judge. We were falling out.
Jane Goodall, she's a whole, you should have seen her with those chimps.
It was disgusting. Like,
and apparently he's a thing in Canada,
like he's a late night dirty comic towards Canada. But,
but it was the dumbest thing. But to see it,
I mean we were pounding on the table, we could not breathe cause he's,
it was all old cheap one-liners like the Catskills.
And he had the suit and,
and he was a gorilla and he would put it all in.
So it was all from a super back mountain gorilla point of view. Like,
what's your point of view? Silverback mountain gorilla is how I see the world.
But the good thing about that act too,
it's like he could die and somebody could just take us. Yeah.
Somebody could take over, you know, and,
and the thing was we picked him for last comic, right.
But then this is where TV kills comedy. So now he's on prime time,
NBC and he can't do that.
Like you can't say she's a whore and you can't do everything that made him
funny, was like, no, the sensors won't allow it. So now people are like,
why is he wearing gorilla hands? Yeah. It just sucks. Yeah.
TV just rip like [inaudible]. Let me see what makes you funny. Okay,
let's not do that. Do you remember Gallagher Two? Yeah. Yeah. Remember his,
that brother, you couldn't afford Gallagher,
so he was doing giant theaters and Gallagher too.
His brother was doing like little comedy clubs. Yeah. Like he,
I would see it like in places that I was working and I was coming up,
it would be like, oh, and then next weekend it's Gallagher too. I'm like,
what's calorie? Do they get into a fight?
Like a legal fight over ownership of cars. Gallagher wanted to come back. Yeah.
See Gallagher apparently like temporarily retired and he sold his act to his
brother Gallagher. And his brother looked
as brother, looked a lot like him. And he had, you know, he just basically it,
he picked up like a job. It's like I have an affiliate or like a, you know,
like a, like syndication. You syndicated the act, you know, if you,
if you want to buy a seven 11 yeah. Well it's like the blue man group,
like this different blue man groups right around the country. Yeah. Yeah,
that's true. But there's no, like it was a blue man.
It was just one blue man.
Maybe that would be but so gallers Gallagher's brother took all the jokes and
the props and started buying watermelons and sledgehammers and just toured the
country.
I would love to be in court when they had that fight. Like your honor,
here's how I smash a watermelon and then is my brother eyes special water like I
be, you decide.
I think it was just a matter of whether or not he could continue to do the act.
But I mean is it his last name? Gallagher? Is it a real name? So it is.
Leo was the original and Ron is the brother, but they look,
then they go on to Gallagher. Right.
It's like if a girl breaks up with you and you fuck are slightly less good
looking sister. I don't know if this is right quite. Yeah.
I think right here is the original original.
This picture here would be the brother, isn't he? Sure I picked up this.
Wow. That is, yeah.
I wouldn't want to be the judge cause I the ballot of Ron Gallagher blog afoot.
It's must someone must read the story about it, but wow. So yeah, they,
it was close enough so you would kind of feel the brothers is Gallagher.
How weird. And so then after a while,
I think Gallagher got tired of being retired and he said,
I'm coming back. And his brother's like, well,
I'm fucking going to continue doing this act. And he's like, no,
you're not bitch. You gonna have to find a new way to make a living. But I only,
I bought it from you. Right. So I own it though.
Like you being in your probably forties and your brother who's like,
if a similar age just picks up comedy and just starts doing your routine like
100% you know, he calls himself Alonzo too. Yeah.
That's crazy. Well, I'm, Charlie Murphy could have done that.
Right? He sounded enough like Eddie that he,
he could, I mean, not, no, no, no, he wouldn't.
But what I'm saying is he could have done it pigging back.
Piggy back to Eddie. But that's such a different way of talking. Yeah.
I mean his, his way of talking was so much more aggressive. Raspy.
Yeah. I missed that dude. Yeah. I had a good fucking time with him, man.
We did a whole tour of the country for 30 days. Oh, nice. Him and Heffron.
Oh yeah, yeah. We just maxim bud light tour.
When you remember what those a, the real men of Bud light,
the what they would sing the real man,
the guy who was commercials. Yeah.
The Guy who sang was the lead singer of survivor.
The eye of the tiger guy. Oh yeah. Yeah. So we were on tour with those guys.
So those guys would sing songs and they had like little punchlines they would do
with the songs and they would have a local guy,
which is actually how I met Thompson girl.
I met Thompson girl because we were doing the Hollywood theater or celebrity
theater, whatever it is in Phoenix. And uh, Segura
was the opening act, the local opening act,
flown them in and I think he did like five or 10 minutes and he was hilarious.
That's how I became buddies with them and start taking them on the road with me.
But then you know,
there'd be the real American hero guys and then it would be half fron and then
trolley and me and we did 22 dates over a month. We had a great fucking time.
I only met him once, but he was real cool. I met him in Vegas and I'm just,
you know, one of those, we were,
it was a dirty at 1230 and we were doing it dirty and he came by and we just,
you know, just hung out backstage. Met Him for a minute. But yeah,
he seemed cool. Couldn't be cool. That was maybe a year or a year,
maybe two years at most before he passed away.
Podcasts in the early, early, early days. We always talked about doing it again,
but it never did it again.
But he had some great fucking stories about Mike Tyson,
but visiting Mike Tyson and Mike Tyson was outside with a tiger and nobody
wanted to get out of the lip.
Well, you know that the tragic thing about comics, right, is when a comic dies,
his act dies with them, you know? Whereas singers,
somebody else will sing the songs. I didn't. But when a comic goes,
so when you have some like Patrice, you know, like that's all gone like that,
you know, and, and so many comics like, yeah, when they're gone,
that act is gone. And you, you remember it and it was hilarious, but nobody can,
you can't, nobody can do their act after that.
I think there was a guy that was doing a bill Hicks tribute show and he was
doing bill hex with all Bill Hicks material and he dressed like him.
And how far did that go? It died that day. Yeah, exactly.
See if you can find that. This is a,
I think they were trying to do that almost like someone trying to be like Mark
Twain.
Like you could do a Samuel Clemens one man show and read the works of Mark Twain
with a goofy mustache on, right. Well, it's like in Vegas, the rat pack,
you know, they can do that, but it doesn't work with comedy. You could,
you could do the rat pack. You can't do don Rickles.
It just, you can't do it. You can't, yeah.
Vegas is a weird place for fucking impersonators, right.
That impersonator life.
I can't imagine it cause some of them are so deep into it. Like I,
we worked, um, you know, I do jazz cruises and uh, they do other crews.
So they had an eighties crews and we had a Michael Jackson impersonator and this
guy stayed in character for the whole cruise to where you want to like, Yo man,
you know, you're not Michael Jack. Like, I mean,
he was like getting off the ship in port, you know what I mean?
Like when you go to the shops or have lunch or with Michael Jackson,
the whole outfit. Outfit Glove. Yeah,
the hair, the makeup that, yeah, it was,
it was weird. Like, and, and you know, it's kind of a strange talent,
right? To be like, yeah, I'm this person. So, so what,
what if that person didn't exist? Who are you? What's your woo?
What's your thing? You know, and, and I heard the prince guy is like that.
I don't know,
but I've heard that is a prince guy who had surgery to look more like prince.
Oh,
there's a few Michael Jackson guys who had surgery look like Michael Jackson.
What do you got Jamie?
Well,
first Google images is just changed this to this and my mic just fucked up.
So this stuff looks weird now, but uh, I found something,
a show that was done about 10 years ago where a guy did a show called Bill
Hicks.
Slight return where he didn't show as if Bill Hicks was still here 10 years
after his death.
Oh, with the like new material. The fuck out.
It's even worse than way. I'm going to preach it.
I'm going to project what Bill Hicks would have thought of today's,
how dare you world. Yeah. South London. Oh,
fucking London. Settle Down London. Stop trying.
That's what I need to get Alex Jones to be Bill Hicks.
Give him a little more hair.
I think that's the closest thing I could find out what you're talking about.
Oh 10 a couple of shows and maybe I read it wrong cause I could've swore there
was a guy who was doing bill Hicks material. He was doing it again.
Hmm?
What does that Bill Hicks, dark poet. Lower right.
Is that actually Hicks in the lower right hand side? The Blue One? Keep going.
Bang. What's that? Yeah, that's it.
Hmm.
That's not, yeah, that's not a hex. That's the guy that pretended to be Hicks.
Let's see. Yeah, that's the guy. That's just,
it's the same show I was telling you about.
BARF. This show is, oh, libre is a ride.
But this show is a bumpy journey that chose death.
Oh yeah. No, this is a different guy. Even
[inaudible] did a show called dark poet. Stop. Look, the way they dress,
everything. Stop. You're not from Texas. Shut your mouth. Go home.
Go home. You fuck. Write your own act. So I'm going to think about,
I'm going to go to Edinburgh and pretend to be bill Hicks and hope nobody here
has ever actually seen him get some surgery.
Looked like the Michael Jackson people like you got to get fucked up. Surgeries.
Yeah. Not Regular certs. You got to get like the fucked up Chin thing. It's a,
it's the weirdest, like again, like you say,
to be an impersonator and now I Guess Queen is, you know,
like as they make these movies, right. So now people are gonna want to be,
they want overnights. Yeah. I want to get an old gotta be mercury. Can you,
can you mess up these teeth? They probably have to wear fake teeth. Yeah. Body.
Y'All are young. That's a crazy ass teeth. What a town.
He said. Yeah. It helped his boy that w that's what he said. You know,
in the movie that he said he could sing at that range because of his shape of
his mouth, which may be true. I don't know. I don't know how it,
how does he know? He didn't never say he's never had a different shape. Mouth.
That's true. Yeah. Well, whatever it was, it worked. He's making lemonade.
That's what it is. But you're right. Like that talent,
you know, that there is,
who's like that now that every bands like that now that you know,
because they just could, queen kept like, every song was different.
Like you knew it was queen,
but it was completely different than the last hit that they did.
That's what was crazy about it.
I think those bands that grew up with no internet,
they will forever be unique because it was a,
it was a different world and the kind of creativity that it took to become those
bands like the kind of creativity that it takes to become the WHO,
you know, like try today the world is like a different place. Like they,
they develop touring and like the Beatles,
they develop touring and performing constantly and writing and,
and you know, I mean, sure, they were influenced by other bands,
but not nearly to the extent that people are today. Yeah.
And also they,
there's kind of a conformity today to the marketing. Like,
we want you to be this so we can sell it. You know, uh, I was playing earth,
wind and fire for somebody and it was one of their instrumentals.
And I told him, I said, well, you know, earth,
wind and fire would also play jazz with Ramsey Lewis.
Like they would the same musicians. And they were like, oh they said,
cause I saw them once and they were doing this whole jazz thing and I wondered
what it was. And it was like, yeah, they were actual musician in a band. Like,
or can you imagine showing up now with a band like yeah, there's 27 of us.
We got a horn section. And in addition to that, they'd be like, what? No,
like we're not paying for actual musicians.
Like those bands had horn sections and rhythm section.
It was a lot of people. How did they make money in it? Well,
they charge a lot for tickets. Well, you know what else?
Seven people on the stage records, right? Records were real records.
So records sales, like when you sold a million records,
you made a lot of money from selling a million records and then you had,
you know, those bands like,
like I did one of these 80 things with war and the number blew my mind,
but then I realized that war sold over 50 million records.
Oh, right. But then when you think about it, yeah,
they had a hit every summer for like six, seven years. Right.
Like why can't we be friends, a low rider, um, on it,
they had a whole list of hit.
Like every one of the songs would start playing like, oh yeah, I noticed,
I noticed song, you know,
50 million records.
So how much did you think each record cost? 10 Bucks. Yeah. Yeah.
What will records nine 99 or whatever like that. So that's fine.
Yeah. And they probably got, they got,
they had to get what at least a buck or two bucks off of each one after
everybody else took their cut. Yeah.
And then the, all the touring money. Yeah, I was,
I was talking to someone who's a band is in a band now.
And they were explaining to me that these record companies,
they don't just take your,
the record sales anymore like iTunes sales and they,
they now take merchandise, they take touring money.
When you sign,
you signed to an all exclusive deal cause the record companies can't really
justify their existence anymore cause they can't really sell it.
Right. You're cancer. Yeah.
Cause all the musicians I know say the only time they sell cds or records or
whatever is at the live show. Like they have to go out and sell.
They like us now, they got to go out and do merge.
Like they didn't have to do that before. It's like yeah,
imagine like you're buying a CD now who's buying the CD? Yeah, look at it.
You know, what am I doing with this thing? Oh yeah, I have a slot for it.
Well yeah that's what people say when they buy them after shows. They're like,
you know, and I joke about like, cause I have cds and download cards.
You said it's a generational.
It is literally the line is right at about the age 40. If they're older,
they want a CD. Right. And I g I said, you know, so,
so if you try to sell them a download card and like what?
I'm not paying you for a business card. What is this? Right.
But then if you get a younger person and you try to sell them a CD,
but where am I gonna play this? My grandfather's house?
My computers don't even come with a drive anymore. Like describe,
so people like,
people want to buy vinyl to sell vinyl because that's a small percentage that
want to buy vinyl. Sound like you're into jazz and shit. Nah, they, Dale,
they're buying, you know what? Jazz fans still have CD players.
Like they made the switch from records to cds and they're like, that's it.
I'm not going back. I'm not sweating.
I'm not getting the records out of the garage to,
there's not a record industry for Jackson a some, but it's for the,
uh, it's footy. Yeah. Yeah. There's some, but it's not big blue notes doing,
um, blue note jazz labels doing records again. And, uh, for their artists,
but they're selling to the younger people, not the older people.
Older people aren't buying turntable new turntables to play it.
That makes sense. You know, where is a good jazz place in la?
Like if I wanted to go see Jan, you know,
the crazy thing about La is all the jazz musicians live here and they all say,
well we don't play here. There's no money to be made. So there there's,
I'm on because it's La, they record here, you know, and they,
um, I'm trying to remember the name of it on sunset.
Catalina bar and grill on sunset is good and Vibrato on Beverly Glen is good.
But Bravo is owned by herb Alpert. Yeah. So is this something like you,
you'll go out like on a Wednesday night or something like that? You'd go see?
No, I do more. Um, I,
I love going to festivals. Yeah. I love going to festivals.
Um, I'm guilty that I,
I'll go to a jazz club in New York more so than I would in la. Really? Yeah.
Why? Cause it's more the vibe, the vibe in New York. It just fits.
That's where they come from. And that's what a jam. Uh, but, but I've been to,
I've been to a few times. I'll go,
definitely if I know somebody who's playing there, I'll go see him at Catalina.
I have never experienced good jazz. I'm sure it's real.
I know you're not dumb. No. This guy, I got a, um, man,
this, what is this Jeremy?
This is Catalina, but [inaudible] performance,
they're kind of frequently eat performed. The only place I've even,
that's the only reason I know of it cause it's on sunset and Hollywood pops up
there. Is He doing stand up? No, he does jazz. He's sings
what? So you did. But this is the thing, and this is the thing about jazz.
So you see that now call up a guy. Look up. Uh,
well do I want to hear some of this?
[inaudible] you got a cigarette?
Okay. Stop.
Yeah. So that,
that's old acoustic jet. But that,
that's the jazz that keeps people from listening to jazz. You know,
that's the Jaffe like, oh, never mind. Uh, look,
you look up a guy like Robert Glasper who's just this brilliant young keyboard
player and he has two bands. He has the Robert Glasper trio,
which is a just a jazz trio, piano, bass and drums, which are brilliant.
Then he's got the Robert Glasper experience,
which is his electronic electric band.
And he'll have everyone singing on that from like Layla Hathaway,
Donnie Hathaway's daughter, who's a brilliant vocalist to loopy fiasco,
you know, to most deaf. They all perform together. He,
he hangs out with the route.
The roots have a jam session in New York that,
that all these jazz artists come to south.
So that's what's going on that I love it. It's really,
I mean jazz has always been the most creative music, you know, it's just, and,
and that's why I love it. These guys are there,
they're masters of their instruments and it's all about creativity and they,
you know, even when they do covers,
it's great cause they do it in such a different way. You know,
I like Robert Glassberg experienced the first time I heard him,
they did smells like teen spirit. And I was like, thank you. He was cool.
He can look at it, he can look up anything.
So that's the kind of thing in jazz, you know, um,
my buddy Marcus Miller, who's this brilliant bass player who was,
he was Luther Vandross, his musical director,
and he did all the music for Luther, right. And that was all great.
But he also produced music for Miles Davis, you know,
and he's done stuff again with, with anybody from like,
you know, Bill withers to, to classic, um,
old school jazz artists. So yeah,
jazz covers a wide range and that's what I love about it.
But there's a lot of young jazz artists now who are bringing in hip hop and,
and
different John [inaudible] into jazz that are making it really cool
international stuff. A lot of African sound coming in,
Brazilian sound coming in. And these are the guys, terrace Martin,
who's in a group called rnr equals now with Glasper terrace.
Martin does all of Kendrick Lamars music really seed sold so fast.
It's, it's like, yeah. It's like, yeah, I'll go with Kendrick Lamar and I, I,
you know, I just, I need to make $5 million, so I'm gonna do this music.
But when I can just create and play and have fun and just be a musician,
then I go to my jazz roots and I jam with these guys in a whole different,
different vibes. So here's right here.
Yeah. Spirit, Jasper.
That's hilarious. What is going on with his head?
What is up there then here? Can't help you with that. That red stripe.
I got nothing. Like what's happening now? It's a hat. That's a hat. Yeah.
I can't be, it's hair, but interesting.
So he's using a vocoder so as he sings, it comes through the instrument.
Wow. These guys gotta be high.
Yeah. Oh yeah. No way around it. Well, that part of jazz never changed. Yeah,
that's, miles Davis has always been fascinating to me.
Like all the people in musical history,
like he's always been like with this one dude. But I was like, wow,
I would have loved to have met that guy. Me Too. So fucking intense. Marcus.
You know, played in this band and knew him,
I would've loved to have seen him just to see him live because, you know, he,
he did a record called kind of blue,
which is the biggest selling jazz record ever.
He did it in 59 it still sells thousands of copies a week.
Like it's still a big, you know, kind of blue is the standard.
But he also played covers of like human nature and time after time,
like in the 80s he was doing covers of that. Wow. You know, so,
so again, that, that was the thing about, about a jazz man. Like he was like,
yeah, well it's good music. So I'm gonna play it. Like I don't,
I don't care for it. It was written by Cindy Lopper or, you know,
Duke Ellington. That's good music. I'm gonna play it. And that,
that's what's so cool about it. But yeah, so, so those are places,
but when you go to the jazz festivals, you know,
whether it be the playboy jazz festival, Newport jazz festival,
but just like our comedy festivals where you get a bunch of musicians who are
like, yeah, we're all here together. Let's let this jam, let's play something.
And sometimes the best music will be random. Not,
not, you know, not part of the set, but like, oh man,
remember when we played together and you know, 97 and mantra. Yeah,
let come on stage and we'll play. And then you hear something that, again,
just like in comedy, when some comics just improv in or you know, they're,
they're doing the same thing. They're, they're Improv to me.
The big compliment I get from jazz musicians when they compliment me on my
Improv, you know, cause it's like, yeah, you guys are experts.
You like Improv is, you guys created it.
So if I'm doing something and you think it's cool, Craig Robinson,
you know Greg? Sure. He's talked about both sides.
Like he's got the comedy and music thing and he's respected on both these.
He's like, the musicians love him and comics love him and he's, yeah,
Craig in Montreal. Craig did a big outdoor show.
Like it was like a block party, like the giant outdoor stage.
Yet Craig played it and it was hilarious cause he's doing his act right.
So it's a big outdoor thing and families with their kids and he's singing take
your panties off. And I'm like, yeah. So this I guess is the uncensored.
But it was hilarious, you know.
Very cool.
I saw dizzy Gillespie once when I was a kid when I was in a kind of,
had to be like second and third grade. I was living in San Francisco,
we had a field trip. We went to see Dizzy Gillespie live.
And I'll never forget it. Like, you know,
his cheeks will blow up like a bull frog. Right. It was like,
but that's not even the way you're supposed to play the trumpet.
Right. And that's what's so great about it. Like nobody,
cause nobody taught him the right way to play it. So he just played it.
Most people don't even know who dizzy Gillespie is. But if you see him live,
you never forget like that. Right? Like what in the fuck?
Like you see his face blow up. Like how, how,
how are you doing that? How is that real?
But so you're supposed to keep your cheeks tight,
like the way they would teach you.
They would never teach you to do that and you probably couldn't.
I know I couldn't, you know, just he just had a way of doing it.
I wonder what year he died.
Don't know. Um,
but I was a little kid when I saw him in,
here's it died and 93 93 in New Jersey. Damn.
I um,
okay.
I met Arturo Sun Deval and they did a movie about him.
Andy Garcia did a movie bounce, so Arturo's really? Yeah.
He's this Cuban trumpet player and I want to say it,
what he was telling the story,
and I want to say it was dizzy Gillespie who was in Cuba and Arturo was like
driving him around. Right. This is like in a, I guess it would be in the late,
maybe early sixties and he asked Arturo what he does and he's like awkward,
like, Oh, I played a trumpet. But the Cubans were like, oh yeah, that's lot too.
Like all the Cubans knew who he was.
So he played and Dizzy Gillespie in the head. I want to say it was, he might,
I might be wrong name, but, but they went to the US State Department,
the head of CBS records and, and said,
we have to get him in the United States. Like we, he has to be here.
And they did it. They, they, the State Department got an Arturo.
Now imagine this show. They went to the State Department.
It was an artists thing. They said, we want this guy to come to the US, to Cuba.
I have no idea. But no, they didn't sneak him out. He,
it was a state sponsored thing.
Like they got him over here to perform and then went back. No,
he came over and stayed. But this was the crazy part. This is the part,
I can't imagine.
So he flies from Cuba into LaGuardia Airport and they take him straight to
Carnegie Hall for soundcheck. And he plays Carnegie Hall that night.
I mean, can you imagine like, imagine your first Gig, right? Like somebody,
somebody saw you, you know, I don't know.
Rodney Dangerfield saw you at a club in Boston and he was like,
okay Joe.
Oh my God, it's a crazy story. And, but to this day,
but Arturo is like, when he plays the trumpet, you know, it's him.
Like he hits notes on the trumpet.
Like only dogs can hear like he's famous for this super high notes and stuff
like that. But yeah, that's, that's what I love about it.
So I loved the creativity. And then, you know, Marcus was telling me,
cause he's from New York, from Queens, seventies eighties guy. He said, well,
you know what happened with hip hop?
He said one of the things was they took music out of the schools, right?
They didn't, you know, they don't teach, you can't take an instrument anymore.
They were like, it's out of the budget probably. He said,
well you can't stop people from creating. So these guys,
they didn't have musical instruments, but they had records.
So they just started making music with their records.
They just started mixing the records and coming up with new sounds and it was
like, yeah, that kind of makes sense.
If you're musical and nobody teaches you to play an instrument,
but you have these records, you're like, all right,
well what if I played this and this at the same time? Right.
And then the next thing you know, they made that hip hop,
which that that hip hop caught on before. Right.
The idea of mixing two different records together until hip hop came around and
no one ever did that with rock and roll there. No, no.
And then hip hop mixed in rock and roll. Right. When you know, when run DMC,
Aerosmith walk this way, that blew people's mind ass. You know, that was like,
wait a minute, that's black and white. What's happening?
Can't play together. Yeah, no. Yeah.
And Adidas Adidas was like, yes they can. And they're wearing Adidas while they,
do you ever listen to any of the brand new heavies?
They did hip hop with the brand. Heavies is
a heavy wood. It's a heavy rhyme experience. Is that what it's called?
It's to this day, one of my, uh, one of my favorite old schools,
like 1990 style rap slash
yeah. The brand new heavies were great. Yeah, they were great.
And then you had living color who I still love. Oh Man.
I've lived in about living color. Yeah, that was a great, and you talk about,
you talk about being ahead of their time,
like think about that song cult a personality today, right? Like,
yeah, right. And, and, and cm punk. Walkout music. Yeah. Yeah.
And that was another band where they were like, okay, let me get this straight.
This is a heavy,
like a heavy metal rock and roll band of black guys who are sampling public
enemy. Right. What the fuck?
Yeah. What are some weird,
some areas he had the crazy hair with the shades and you would wear the, uh,
he would wear the wet suits all the time. That's, yeah. He,
he's like a saw school, like scoop suits. Yeah. He used to jam and those, yeah.
Yeah. That is what he's wearing.
I just want to show his dick off. Hey Yo, rock star. Why not? Back in the day,
like you ever see like those Robert Plant,
these tight pants on his hog that he's wearing a suit.
He's wearing a wetsuit when God damn Hispanics went to so weird.
That was his thing. Oh Wow. They fucking vanished. What happened to them?
They w they came back out, they did the 25th anniversary. I saw it at hard rock.
They did the 25th anniversary of their record of vivid cult of personality yet.
And they toured it. Silly swimsuit.
Wow. How crazy. Yeah, that was
great fucking song. But you know, that's always freaked me out too.
Like imagine being a band. You have one song that just out of the park,
just in the parking lot, you know, just one fucking grand slam home run.
God Damn, we did it. This is huge number one song in the nation.
Seven weeks in a row
and nothing. Well yeah, but, but imagine like, well what did they say?
You got your whole life to write that song. Yeah.
And then we got two years to write the night. Right to do it again,
but this also looks like some bands, they just catch fire with what?
Like do you remember warrant Cherry Pie.
She is match giant fucking huge song and that was it.
That dude died near here and he died in woodland hills and a fucking shitty
hotel somewhere.
I'm going to give you the one hit wonder. You want it? Okay. The twist,
the twist. What did Chubby checker ever sing? Oh my God.
Come on.
Imagine that you had the song that was like, yeah,
that was the, what's Chubby checker's number two hit. I don't know.
That's a great point because,
but that somehow or another was good enough for him to stay famous for his whole
life. Your whole life.
People hire you to play one song.
He was the greatest one hit wonder ever. Then he was the eyes. The kid. Yeah.
He said go to the edge. Yeah.
I can't even imagine anyone who's come close to that because no one's paying
them to sing. Sing called the personality. No one's all excited. No,
you call it, you might have one fan who's like worth millions.
Who pays you to come birthday party and treats you like shit. Yeah,
giving extra money. Am I gonna pay on you? Do you remember?
And then living color, the TV show, living color came out. Yeah.
And then it was like, wait,
what are you doing that there's already a band that's not us?
The show far eclipse the bar. Eclipse the band. And then they were like,
were you named after the show? Right? Like how many? Like, like a,
what's the name? Darrius Rucker. How many times does he said my name is not,
who'd he?
Well who these back apparently cause Darrius Rucker went off and did country
music and did that for a long time. But now he's back. He's back on tour.
Yeah, man. Yeah. That was another band.
That band was that fucking first record.
The second record fell up at that first record was,
I think it was like serious or something.
But like they played it and then I went back and played it again. It was like,
wow, I forgot how good this was. Like that album is,
but the second one was not as good.
I don't think that was one of those albums though.
There's something about hoody were some people despise them and it didn't make
any sense to me. It's like some people just heard those songs too many times.
It was too big of a hit and they were like all fucking Hoodie.
That does happen though. Like Dave Matthews. Yeah.
When something's too much of a hit and you hear it every day,
you get tired of the sun and then you just don't play that. You know?
A buddy of mine, actually mal hall, he's gonna love this shout out.
So mal hall opens for me, really funny guy,
and he tours with Angela Johnson.
He hates happy that song. I'm happy. Yeah,
by Farell.
I insist on it being his walk on music. Whenever we work, it's,
oh, he physically,
he has a physical reaction because how much did we hear that song when it came
out? It was like drilled it. So yeah, so now he knows people.
It's good for them to get angry. Before Joey Diaz, whenever I'd worked with him,
he would just decide, he would pick a thing and it wasn't like,
like we were talking about this,
but I recognize what he was doing after awhile and he'd be backstage and he
would pick a thing and just start getting fucking mad at it.
He's fucking pussies. This is what they think Americans,
this is what they think the fucking world is. And he would start getting crazy.
And then ladies and gentlemen, Joey Diaz,
and he would go on stage with that momentum and just mark the place.
I've had that happen a couple of times with something just got,
I remember it was one of those, you know when you do the set,
you wish you had recorded it? Yes. So I was going to the laugh factory.
It's Saturday night and I was on my bike and this guy,
like it's stopping go right. And I'm just, and he hit my bike,
but it was only at like five miles an hour.
Like he just tapped me and knocked the bike over. But I'm like, I was bright.
Like how did you not see me? Right.
And I just went on stage and I just ranted about, you know,
drivers and traffic and this and it was hilarious and it was like gone.
Did you record it? No, I never recorded. I do sometimes,
but I didn't record that one. And I wish I, because it was just, you know,
sometimes you just get something gets to you right before you go on stage and
you, it's not written, you just go into a rents, but it's right there.
But that's why it's so important to record everything. Yeah.
I record all of them. Yeah. I have them on my phone. It's so easy now. Yeah.
Now this was before phones. This was before we carried a studio in our pocket.
Oh, this is a while ago. This was when these are all set.
This is when you had the, uh, the micro cassette.
I still have a bunch of those tapes. Those, I used to have lunch room out.
I'm like, I don't even want to hear them. I, um, I used to have a,
a little tiny mini cassette recorder. A mini desk. Yeah,
I remember the many days. Yeah. That was when Sony kept trying formats,
like maybe they'll buy this, right? They'll buy. So yeah,
we bought many disk once they fucked him with Beta Max,
then you sons of bitches did anyone but comics by many disks.
Like I set up a mini disc recorder at the comedy store.
I actually installed one.
I installed the mini district quarter at the comic store so I could record my
sets. Yeah, yeah. Comics. We used them. I don't know if anyone else did.
I mean it just didn't work. They really never sold music on it.
So it was a fun man. It never really took off.
But then it was like cdrs, right? Yeah.
You can record on record on cdrs. Yeah. All that stuff is like,
we thought that was the shit.
I had a block could make my own cds right on it with a sharpie.
That's technology, man. It happens so fast. Especially in this era. Yeah.
I mean think about how long records existed for yeah.
Decade after decade after decade.
It was just records and all of a sudden compact discs. And you're like, what?
Right. Cause. Yeah cause that started what around 1990 like laser disc
and then they have movies that relays or just to ask my brother,
my brother's a techie, like an early adopter.
So he has all that shit in his garage. So yeah, he's got some movies on 12 and
still collect those. There's a thing was out there, somebody,
somebody spying eight tracks somewhere.
Somebody in their home right now watching top gun on laser disc. All excited.
Yeah. And Hit, they invite you over like hey, check this out and you're like,
I can just hit the remote in instantly.
The place that's the most incredible thing is like you could ask Siri to play a
song. Yeah. Sit like, like you know like
play whole lot of love bitch. Listen to me.
Hey Siri, play whole lot of love by led Zeppelin.
Well what kind of a world we live in. Yeah. Well that's like those commercials.
And again, getting back to the Special Ed,
talk about like the arguments between Siri and Alexa.
Like that's going to be the next thing. Yeah. I think Alexis,
more of a spy that bitches sneak. She's listening more.
Alexis listening all that time listening all the time. Siri,
you have to talk to her. Yeah, but you hear this. Yeah, we think we think,
but you don't, you know, they,
the privacy's in illusion now,
like when people, I'm off the grid like, no, you're not. None of us,
none of us are off the grid. So you know, they say like your,
your social security number yet everyone,
anyone can find it or your credit card numbers. Like anything you do,
it's out there. Well, there was a new, um,
there's a new technology that the government is unleashing that is, uh,
a weather balloon or a balloon that from 65,000 feet,
it can watch multiple cars at the same time and tracked them 65,000 feet in the
air. My, can you even see what the fucks, I mean, no,
you wouldn't even be able to see it up there, but that's, you know,
that's not that new. I mean, you know,
this is apparently like the super high tunnel. I mean the,
just the idea of watching from that Jaime,
and they've had spy planes and stuff like that. They could, you know,
what was that a movie I in the sky, like, yeah. Hackman or something. Yes.
Smith wasn't with the satellites. Yeah. That was a, yeah,
that was a movie where Gene Hackman would like,
like will Smith made a phone call and gene Hackman had to blow up his lab.
Damn. Uh, yeah. Back when I was in the aerospace, you know,
they had airplanes that would like, they're flying at 80,000 feet,
keeping an eye on things. Yeah. You know, and they,
they had cameras and now it's just so much more prevalent and yeah,
when you know, you've got, listen man, you, your car, right?
All the new cars have a black box in them that people don't realize. Like,
so if you have an accident, they can find out how fast you were going. Oh yeah.
When you cry or if you have a warranty thing and they're like, yeah,
but you are it at 150 miles an hour, blah, blah, blah.
[inaudible] got some cars,
have a box in them where the police can shut your car down. Like saved.
You're in a high speed chase in a corvette or something like that.
I don't know if at the core of that,
but some kind of car like that that's electronically controlled.
They literally can get your vin number plugged into a machine and say shut it
down. They can do that with um, onstar. Right.
If the car is stolen on start, just shuts the car off. Yeah. Yeah.
Have you seen those new plates, those electronic plates? Yeah.
I know it's weird, but when you call it in, like say someone stole your car,
then the plate changes to stolen. Oh really? Yeah. I didn't know that. Yeah.
Now it's like a little more down. Don't get your eyes lit up. It's good. No,
cause I was thinking how many people could mess with you like that.
Like now that you're just open for a practical joke, somebody like, hey man,
let's report his car stolen. Yeah, because that's true.
Because who do they know? Like on the phone,
they don't know if it's you and all you need is the Vin or something minutes.
What do you need? Do you need some sort of second party verification?
Did they send you a text message? Reply to this if your car is really stolen,
you know, I doubt it. Yeah. Good point. Your ex wife,
she's probably like this mother fucker calling your car stolen. Yeah.
She would have all your info, right? Like, yeah,
this is some bitch every Saturday night or she knows you're doing something,
man, do it. Your stolen car your best. This is our,
our privacy's so deteriorated from the time that we were kids to today.
Like it makes you really wonder how far it can keep slipping.
The only, but the other side of the coin is they don't like, no,
most people don't care. You know what I mean? In other words,
you're not that important. Like pillow to government spying on me. Like,
well no,
they're not because you're nobody like you're not doing anything that they would
be interested in. Don't flatter yourself. Yeah, exactly. It do what?
What did you do? But then there's the other side like, Hey,
if you're not doing anything wrong, you shouldn't worry about the government.
Hey, they can go look in my email. I'm not doing anything wrong.
That's not the point. The point is, the government is people, right?
And people shouldn't have access to your email and who knows what kind of weird
shit they're doing like theirs.
That was one of the things that Edward Snowden said that the government is like
sneaking in on people's emails and looking at People's Dick pecks and looking at
the end state. You look at all of all those things, and that's a sliding scale,
right? Between Security and privacy and all of that,
that you have to figure out what you're comfortable with. And you know,
shameless plug number to my podcast. No, I'm part of this new podcast.
It's called fear not who's on it with you?
A guy named Barry Glassner and Barry Glassner wrote this book called the culture
of fear, and it was all about how fear is used as business, right?
They keep you scared so that they could sell you things,
whether it be security systems or [inaudible],
there's so much involved in it and,
and it's about what we're scared of versus what the real threats are in it.
You know what I mean? Like he's like, yeah, wait, they keep you scared of,
you know, your kid getting kidnapped in the park.
Like you kid ain't going to get kidnapped in the park.
But what you should be scared of is a number of drunk drivers on the road.
That's real. And the, the,
the odds of you getting hit by a drunk driver between like midnight and 2:00 AM
when the bar, like that's a real fear. And,
and we talk about it in the context of different things. We did the,
the whole anti-vaxxer thing and you know, so what's, what's you, yeah,
you're worried about your kid getting, getting something from the vaccination,
but the greater good is society is protecting itself against measles or whatever
disease, you know. So we, we talk about things like that and, and yeah, there's,
there's always that sliding scale of um,
personal security or whatever versus the government, you know, and,
and again, the government, if the government did its job right,
you could trust them a lot more. Sure. You know what I mean?
Like the government and the, in other words, this is just my opinion,
like taxes. Okay. A lot of people, I hate paying taxes.
I don't mind paying taxes because I understand the greater good.
We need to fix roads and we want to have good public schools and cop blah blah
blah. Yeah man.
But the problem is that the government gets the money and then they fuck up.
Yeah. So, so that's why you don't want to pay,
cause you know that this politician is paying his brother who's a contractor to
do some bullshit work and stealing, you know, so that,
and, and you know, what's the solution? I don't know.
I mean we're all wondering what's the solution. There is a solution
on the horizon.
Did you see what happened with Neil degrasse Tyson that Neil degrasse stars and
got in trouble for tweeting something the other day after the mass shootings.
Right. People are pissed at him because it pulled up,
pulled the tweet up cause it's pretty interesting cause it's, it's just
accurate.
And people were angry and they're saying he's using his platform irresponsibly
and no,
he was trying to let people know that although these shootings are a tragedy,
they are a small number of deaths and there's so many other deaths that
happened. Here it goes, the past 48 hours,
the USA horrifically lost 34 people to mass shootings on average across 48
hours. We also lose 500 to medical errors, 300 to the flu,
250 to suicide, 200 car accidents, 42 homicides via handgun.
Often our emotions respond more to spectacle than to data.
Now that is not a bad tweet.
But I saw a scientist who was writing, I am unfollowing him.
He is using his platform irresponsibly. A lot of fucking virtue signaling.
Really, because what he's saying is not that there's anything wrong with,
uh, you know, feeling her horrified by these tragedies. I mean,
he's saying we horrifically horrifically 34 people to mass shootings,
but he's saying it's interesting that there's people dying left and right all
throughout this country all day long, just not at the hands of one person.
So we look at it differently and he's just saying,
he just giving you data as a scientist, that's exactly what it is.
He's a science. Yes.
And so a scientist can separate the emotion,
but people don't find this apology because as soldier soldiers,
even more interesting,
people will consider a mass shooting much worse than,
you know, heart attacks. Yeah. So listen to this.
So this is the other thing.
Yesterday I posted in reaction to the horrific mass shootings in America over
the previous 48 hours,
killing 34 people spawned mixed and highly clear critical responses.
If you missed it,
I offered a short list of largely preventable causes of death along with their
average two day death toll in the United States.
They significantly exceeded the death toll from the two days of mass shootings
including the number of people 40 who on average die from handgun homicides
every two days.
I then noted that we tend to react emotionally to spectacular incidences of
death with the implication that more common causes of death trigger milder
responses within us.
My intent was to offer objectively true information that might help shape
conversations and reactions to preventable ways we die.
Where I miscalculated was that I genuinely believe that the tweet would be
helpful to anyone trying to save lives in America.
What I learned from the range of reactions that a is that for many people,
some information, my tweet in particular can be true but unhelpful,
especially at a time when many people are either still in shock or trying to
heal or both. So if you are one of those people,
I apologize for not knowing in advance what effect my tweet could have had on
you.
I'm therefore thankful for the candor and depth of critical reactions shared in
my Twitter feed. As an educator,
I personally value knowing with precision and accuracy. What reaction?
Anything that I say or write will instill in my audience,
and I got this one wrong, respectfully submitted,
and then it says Neil degrasse Tyson. Now even that people were saying,
not enough, not good enough of response. It's almost like today,
there's certain people today to d they don't give a fuck whether or not you're,
you're saying something with sincerity. Whether you are sorry, they don't,
sorry is not enough. Like they don't, they just want,
they want to be mad at you. And even if you're, sorry,
if you admit you made a mistake, there's no forgiveness.
There's no road to redemption. There's no, there's no,
I get what you were doing.
I think that it depends on, you know, as far as is the,
sorry enough for whatever depends on the pattern of the person.
Now with Neil degrasse Tyson, this is what I think happened
in here. It is my opinion. He's a scientist. So he gives the information.
So he saw this and said, oh, wait a minute,
this many people died from medical mistakes. This may be,
and people didn't react what he doesn't, where he messed up with the timing.
Yes. You don't say that the day after the mass shooting,
you say it maybe a week later or something like, Hey, you know,
people die in a lot of weight, blah, blah, blah. Now what he's saying is,
I didn't know that I'm a scientist. I didn't,
I wasn't aware of the emotional impact.
Thank you for telling me the emotional impact and I'm sorry that I hurt people's
feelings, which to me is totally legitimate.
Especially coming from who he is and what,
what I would think the scientific mindset is.
Now there are some people that, yeah, exactly what you said.
They decided you're a terrible person for saying this,
so that apology isn't enough. There's nothing he could do,
but see that there's certain people, right?
There's nothing you can do that's going to change their mind. You know,
you look at, look at the Obama birth certificate, right?
So even when the birth civic came out,
there's a certain percentage of the people that are still like,
what now that's fake.
Like there was no way he was ever going to be American to these people or what
they, there's a certain, you know, you, you travel,
you know like [inaudible] there's certain groups like you ain't going to get
them. Their minds made up in their, in their bubble.
They're in their whatever it is, and they,
they're surrounded by likeminded people. Like you said,
like this is the disadvantage of the Internet, right?
The advantage of the Internet is all of this information. The disadvantages.
You find people who only think like you and you only talk to them and you build
this bubble wealth. Well, yes. So there's a group of people, a percentage,
I don't know, however you want to describe it,
that decided the moment he said that this is an unfeeling, horrible person,
blah, blah, blah. I mean, I said, you know, my thing with the,
with the mass shootings, I'm like, listen, we don't care.
We say we care individually. Like it's very sad for that family.
It's very, to me,
the worst part of a mass shooting is somebody went to Walmart that day.
They didn't know what's going gonna be the last day of their life.
They never going to see their family again. Somebody went out to a club in,
in Ohio, they didn't know they'd never come.
That's the tragic part. And that is sad. But in the grand scheme of things,
we don't do anything. We don't, you know, we,
we say it doesn't work before we even try it.
Like there's nothing we do that changes. Even after Vegas,
when they said they were gonna ban, what was it called?
The bump stop or whatever it was,
that thing that helped shoot faster and then ultimately they didn't even band
that. You know, so,
so as a society we say we care,
but we don't because we don't change anything. You got to change something.
Nothing changes. If nothing changes, right.
Well then we're getting way off track here. But with Neil, the grass, Tyson,
the, the outrage thing didn't outrage me. No, no, I didn't outrage you either,
right? No,
because he's assigned what he said is truth and data is true and data is
delivered without emotion.
And why people were upset is because he delivered truth with no emotion.
Right. And he said, he said horrifically. I mean,
he was talking about the tragedy. Yeah.
The thing is that just people are looking to be upset. Oh, absolutely. Yeah.
Absolutely. People look for for something to be mad about. Yeah.
Or something to be outraged about and that you know what that takes away from it
takes away from real outrage. Yes. Right. Yeah. It diminishes it.
If you're outraged every day, then you know, then, okay,
so what's really outrageous, right? If I'm going to be upset,
if I'm going to be upset at a scientist for giving me scientific data,
what do I want? Yeah. I guess the timing was the issue.
The timing was issue wasn't an issue with me. I mean, I get what he's doing.
I'm not a moron. It's simple.
He was just giving you all sorts of different horrific deaths that occur all
throughout the country. And I think on that same weekend,
there was some unprecedented number of people that were shot and killed in
Chicago. Chicago was a fucking Chicago's. And it's like, you know,
it's a war zone. And the thing is, you know, people say what about the gun laws?
And it's like, yeah, but [inaudible] all you gotta do is go to Indiana.
Like you go two hours away and you can get whatever you want. Just, you know,
that's the, that's the thing. So,
so having a car as a city Chicago is like, look, we were trying,
but we can't, you know,
what are we going to set up borders and check every car coming into Illinois?
God Damn, man, you'd have to go in every house. Exactly. So you can't,
you can't do that. Yeah, it's, it's, but yeah, his thing, I think it was a time,
and I'm like, you, that didn't offend me. I get what he was saying.
And then this is sh can't offend you.
You're a rational human that can offend you.
You know what bothers me when people pretend to be ignorant of something and
they're not? How so what when people like, like for example with this,
like there's some people like, oh we can use this to,
to create some dislike against Neil Tyson or,
or whatever. It's generally, it's generally politicians do it right when they,
they say something and they're like, oh,
I didn't know that was offensive or wrong. It's like, yes you did,
but you know, your followers didn't you see what I mean?
Like you can give me an example. I'm trying to, trying to think of an example.
Okay, well, well with the mass shootings, right? So,
so the whole thing of saying that Trump's tweets had nothing to do with it.
Yes, they did get, nowadays they didn't directly. But yeah,
it did normalize.
And this guy used the same language of the, you know, invasion,
et cetera. So you can't say that it's completely unrelated.
You know what I mean? You can't, you can't, don't print. And again,
it's not saying direct, but,
but you can't pretend there's no connection and direct people quotes.
There are people who are intelligent enough to know that, but they'll say, no,
no, there's no, and it's like, yes there is. And you know,
there are don't feign ignorance. That's what I mean. But you know,
the guy in Dayton,
the really fucked up one was that guy's an Elizabeth Warren supporter who
actually wrote about gun control. I mean,
he was just a horrific homicidal fucking psychopath.
And then listen, that you have to have some,
there has to be something wrong with you to do that. You're like, even,
you know, regardless of your political beliefs,
there has to be something wrong with you.
But you can be sparked or you can be Egged on. Sure.
Yeah. By the words of,
of leaders or political people or powerful people and didn't have influence.
Perfect way to put it, yet people of influence.
And that's why I think people of influence have to be responsible in what they
say. Yeah. You know, but, but this, but Neil degrasse Tyson,
this is a different thing.
I think this is just a case of a scientist pointing out information without,
you know, like, like uh, you know, you were talking about earlier, dorks, nerds,
whatever you want to say. Th where it's like, yeah,
well this is just information. I'm not trying to be emotional. And people like,
well,
you have to be happy to connect you even though you're from a lab environment.
You have to understand not everyone is, but that's not, that's a,
one of the more uncomfortable things about today with social media is that
there's a bunch of people that are really just, they're just authoritarian.
They're there, they demand certain types of behavior,
and they do some under the guise of compassion. They do so under it.
Like they're trying to enforce the way people communicate.
Like the Neil degrasse Tyson thing, this you use,
there's no indication whatsoever that he was minimizing the no deaths,
but people are pretending that he's doing. So, yeah,
there were some people who believe he did,
but there were a lot of people pretending to be offended to be upset.
They're finding a nice target. Right. I, you know,
there's too many voices. Alonzo, too many words,
too many people out there spewing. Again,
that's the days we spew the positive and the negativity of the Internet. Yeah.
That's a positive and a negative. The positive is everyone has a voice.
The negative is everyone has a voice. But this is no,
and everyone's like,
and the thing is the, the middle, the comments,
voices, the, the reasonable voices are the least heard. Of course.
Yeah. Well that's Facebook, right? Facebook's algorithm favors outrage.
So if you are on Facebook and you get upset about abortion,
that's the kind of shit you're going to get in your feet, right?
If you get mad about climate change, they go,
you're going to get a lot of climate change talk.
That's what's going to show up. And God damn, that makes people nuts. I mean,
oh, again, and this is living in a bubble. You don't get to hear the other side,
you know, and, and, and, and it's not even the,
it's the reasonable part of the other side. You know what I mean?
Like politically. Yeah, I'm left.
I have friends who I call reasonable Republicans and I could talk to a
reasonable Republican, can't talk to a crazy Republican. Right. You know,
if you, if you say that the mass shootings are based on transgender marriage,
then we can't talk. We, we got nothing. I can, I'm sorry I can't work with you.
But if you say that taxes should be lower to stimulate the economy and blah,
blah, blah. Yeah, we could talk about that in, you know what I mean? That's,
that's, that's the difference. Um, and you know, and just,
just like on the left, look, I believe in the environment, this and that.
But now if you're asking me to give up gasoline, we may have a problem.
I may not be ready to go that far just yet. Here's my thought.
If there's too much co two in the air,
can we make something to suck CEO two out of the air? Why are we wasting,
I mean, wouldn't that be better to me? There are certain air filters,
just giant air filters.
There were certain forms of technology were areas I don't understand.
This is the one that bugs me to down here.
Can we come up with a better way to build a road? But what's a better way?
I don't know, but, but the, that's my point.
There's some really smart people out there.
It takes forever to do road construction like you said about what you got to do.
Well, that's what I'm saying. No, somebody, somebody,
somebody's got to come up with them with a better way. Like when, uh, you know,
really bought more roads. Well, fixing them,
we got to fix them just fucking later or concrete or whatever the fuck it is.
Like the high speed train thing, right? Like, I don't know.
How long have you been in la? 94. I moved here. Okay.
I moved here in 80. Damn right out of, right out of high school.
I came here. So ever since I've been here and ever since you've been here,
they've been talking about a high speed rail. Yes.
From San Francisco to La to Las Vegas, right, isn't you?
I'm just going to do that now though. The hyperloop, this is my point.
Companies like Lockheed, Rockwell, Northrup,
these aerospace companies have come up with, you know,
stealth aircraft hypersonic Echo.
You can't tell me that if you went to Lockheed and said, listen,
here's $10 billion,
we need a train that'll go 200 miles an hour from San Francisco to La to say
that they couldn't do it. They absolutely, you know what I mean?
They have the scientists and the technology wait like we spend so much money on
the wrong shit. Like I get, we need defense and this and that. But yeah,
let's cut 20 billion to the side to figure out how to move people around more
efficiently. Cause that's, these companies do,
these are engineering and design companies. They come up with shit like this.
They, you know, so, so I've always said, why not just do that? Why not?
Why not take some of this brain power and this engineering and development and
use science for the masses. So now if you had, because if you had that,
think about if you could just go to the train station and get to Vegas in two
hours or hour and a half, how many people wouldn't drive if it was that easy?
You know, flying to Vegas is a pain in the ass, right?
You've got to go to the airport and then you've got to go, you know, you,
you're doing all,
you spend spending an hour getting ready for a 40 minute flight. Right?
But a train is so much easier if, if it existed. Yeah. If it exists,
why is it easier than a plan?
Because you just get on and you go and you can do things on the train.
Do you ever,
you ever like back east from going from DC to New York?
I found it's easier to do it on a train.
It's the same amount of time is going to the airport flying and getting to your
cause cadets and they traveled to and from security and that time he just sit in
the train and sit in the train. You got Wifi, you got every, you know,
it's easy and you go from downtown to downtown.
That's the other thing about trains. They don't go to airports,
which are way out there downtown to downtown. Where do you go on a train from?
LifeSafe say from downtown DC to Penn station. Like an old tiny person. No,
I've, no, there's an express train I found. No, you know, I found this,
I found this out from people who do it. They realize, oh yeah,
that's the best way. Three, three and a half hours. Oh, that's not bad. Yeah.
Yeah. You're definitely, it's better than driving. Yeah.
And it probably goes just as fast as a car. Probably not any faster than a car.
No, no fast. But if we had a high speed train that can travel it, you know,
200 miles an hour or whatever, 180 whatever those bullet trains, travel.
And I was just in Italy, we took the train over the countryside.
It was beautiful. It was fun. Not, not bad. No. Just sitting down and relaxing.
They come by, you know, get a diet coke. It's a different, yeah,
it's a different form of try again,
not the most efficient but comfortable and disturbed me so much though.
When the crash, when those motherfuckers derailed. Yikes. Yeah, that well,
cause that's a lot of a lot of energy and there's no seatbelts now it's
everybody just goes flying. Yeah.
You'll just put fucking seatbelts on trains because who's gonna wear them?
I would wear them some, I guess. Funny.
There's not really an abrupt stop. Very old logging road.
That's the problem is when someone fucks up. Yeah.
There's a very abrupt stop. Right. But that's true. You know that's true.
Your car. Yeah. But you wear a seatbelt in your car. Yeah.
Hopefully there's still people who don't, which just blows my mind. Well,
how about you? You're on a motorcycle. Yeah. No,
they talk about how crazy we are.
I've got an explosive fluid between my legs above a hot engine and my only air
bag or minis and your sin Saint Joe. But going in between cars too.
But it's easy to park. Yes. You don't drive a car at all, right? Oh yeah.
I drive Jew, but well, you know, when I drive,
like yesterday I was driving around. What kind of car? You got?
Some stuff right now I've got a truck, I got a um, a raptor.
Ooh. Yeah. Big Ass fucking filler truck. Yeah,
it's, it's fun. Um, I'm almost over it. Really? Yeah,
it had about a year and it's like, okay, I'm almost done with this truck thing.
It's fun to have this big ass truck. Like this.
A girl was in the truck with me and his car was pulling on and I was like, oh,
he ain't gonna hit me. And if he does, I'm not even gonna stop.
I'm gonna win. Like he's gonna hit my tire and I'm going to run over his hood.
But uh, yeah, but you know, that's just me. I get bored with stuff, right.
So I drive something for a year, year and a half, and I'm like, all right,
I'm over it. Let's try something else. So Lisa's, no, no,
because Lisa's are harder to get out of. Oh, that's true. Oh,
so you just know how you are. I, I've learned, I've,
I have wasted enough money over the years. I have bought my way out of shit.
You know who my brother used to love it because I would lease something.
This is what I found out.
So if you lease something for three years and you want to get rid of that too,
they're like, yeah, fine, but you still gotta pay us for the third year.
So I would call my brother like, Hey Ben, you want to drive this thing?
I gotta pay for it anyway. And he's like, ship it
back. He, no, he would pay the ship and I like, like I can't pay the shit,
but yeah, and you would just keep paying the bill and pay it anyway.
You have to get it back to the, you could return it there.
You could return it to any dealership. So if you lease, like I had a, a,
what was it, the infinity at 45 and something and he,
yeah, so he just returned it to an infinity place there.
And so you realized after a few of these fuck ups, this is, yeah,
just buy it and sell it. You know?
And I hope like what I found is I'm not the only one with this disease.
Like there's a bunch of us out there,
so I try to buy it from the guy who's just like me. Like I bought my raptor,
it was like five months old. It had like 3000 miles.
So like, cause that guy had the sickness, you know what I mean? So he was like,
man, I gotta get rid of this rafter. I was like, yeah, okay, I got it.
If you're a single guy and you don't,
and you have a good job like you and you don't have real financial obligations,
yeah, yeah. It's, it's so you, you just wanna try something different.
So it's like, okay, I don't know. I don't know. You know, I was,
I've been looking around and a buddy of mine just went for the new corvette.
He just put his money down on that and I was talking and then,
then I started looking. I was like, Whoa, this might be like,
I always had a problem with Corvettes because I've driven them. They're good.
They were a little small inside.
And also there's the baggage of having a corvette, right? Yeah. Oh look,
a middle aged single guy in the corvette, but this new one,
I don't think it carries that. I don't think it carries it.
I don't think he carries the creeper factor, you know?
Oh well the creeper factor or fire, it'll, it'll fire up eventually.
I feel like it's a,
it's definitely the next step in terms of like design and evolution.
It just looks better. Oh, it's bad ass car. Yeah. I think,
I think they got a big hit. You know,
it has a gps that recognizes where you are and raises the nose up and so you
don't hit bumps in chits.
Speed bumps until it knows where like low dry are. Yeah.
It's crazy. Yeah. We had that, like Rolls Royce had that way to like,
there's a camera that sees bumps in adjust the suspension for the bumps coming
up in front of you. That's the milliseconds. Yeah.
The new corvette is the fastest ever zero to 62 which is amazing because it's
200 plus horsepower less than the Zio six or the dizzy Zr one rather.
And it's still way faster, which is crazy as well. The design is, I mean,
it's going to be a phenomenal, phenomenal cars.
So I don't want to be an earlier adopter though. I don't know if I'd be that.
Whoo. God Damn, that looks good in black. Yeah. Wow.
Look at that fucking thing. That's to be, you know,
and they're going to be all shit gonna be all over La. Holy Shit.
That thing looks good. It'd be a bad ass car.
That is as good looking as an American car has ever been. Yeah. Literally.
And you know something that's like, like the Ford Gt cost, what?
Like a half a million dollars, not 60 grand.
This is 60 with the dealer markup, they'll get 70 for it.
And I bet it's just as fast. Yeah, I bet it's pretty close.
And it still has a trunk. Yeah, there's a trunk in the front end. The back,
right. That is nasty. Yeah. So that might be next. Why not, man,
I might be next. Fuck. Look at that God damn thing.
That's going to be bad ass. I love a good looking car.
It's going to be a bad ass monster car and the top comes off. Woo.
That's a beast, man. And that's the entry model.
And wait until they start pumping, when they start pumping up and see,
oh six and the year one. When is that gonna Happen?
I think in 2021 or 22 two zero s I can't wait.
I was going to ask, you're going to get one now that I'm looking at this.
Thank you. That's why I was, yeah, it's probably hard to get them.
Yeah, there's a waiting list and it, you know,
the dealers are gonna get a mark up and for sure that thing's nasty.
Tony Hinchcliffe fast one. You're not this one. His last year's one.
It's fucking amazing. So they're great cars. Great cars. Well,
you know who's going to get one like Leno is going to get,
does he get the first one or like which, which one did she get? Yeah,
he probably gets garage. Yeah. Fuck yeah, it's, I should say garages. Yeah.
It's gotta be confidence warehouses. Yeah, it's, it's, it's,
but you know what, it's what any,
any car nut would do with unlimited cash. Yes. Yes. Right.
If you had unlimited funds in Europe,
you're a gear head and he's truly a gear head. Like he knows his stuff.
Like he doesn't just buy it, like he actually knows all about it. Yes.
Fabrication Machinery in his studio.
He's build fenders. He's had it for so long. That's the thing.
It's not like three d printing isn't new to him. No.
I remember he has this jet powered car and the wheels,
he was telling me about the wheels and he said that he showed me they brake dust
won't stick to him. Like you know how that you get that black dusty Andy?
And he said, yeah, I'll call. He sent me the hunk of aluminum, like what?
They sent him the metal and he made the wheels like, are you kidding me?
Like that's,
that's the extent of machining you have that you can just make the wheels for
[inaudible] ridiculous. Brilliant.
He's making a wheel that is so preposterous. Yeah.
His place is a trip, man. I mean,
you could wander around it for hours and he loves explaining everything to you.
Oh, my favorite was, you know, he, he'll, he'll let you take in a group.
Right. And he's really cool about this. He's like,
you donate money to a charity. And then he's like, okay,
you can bring in this many people. So it's almost like it's not selling tickets.
It's helping charity, you know, he does it cool now. Yeah, it was really cool.
So he had this guy and the guy passed away. I can't remember his name,
onset was Jimmy something. But, but this was the guy who would give tours.
So he's walking around and he's like, this is this, this, what is it?
When did we get this one? It was so, he's like, what the hell is this?
He's probably always picking Shit up, right? Yeah. It was a guy, I was like,
well, where did this come from? What is dies?
The only thing I can think is they make it a museum. Yes.
That's the only thing that got paid off. That's a good move.
I'm charged tickets. I would think I pay,
I would think he probably has something set up to maintain it.
I hope so. Because how are you going to sell those things? What are you going,
you know what I mean? Like what the fuck's gonna buy that steam car, right.
One of the steam cars like this, like a few steam cars,
just ones with metal wheels that he actually had rubber installed on the outside
of the metal wheel so he could drive around town. Yeah.
And then he has those giant cars that are like 25 feet long,
but they only seat two people that look like two V12 engines in the front of
you. And Yeah. But it's fantastic though, you know, and,
and you know that. I, I love that. Um,
and there's a few people like that, but I don't know.
But anyone who does it on the scale? No, no, he does.
I mean j Jerry Seinfeld is uh, he's got, he's just Porsche. He's all,
which is weird. Corolla.
Adam has m Paul Newman's old race cars. You have,
you have been to his spot? Yes. Yeah.
He's got Paul Newman's old Nissan and Dotson race cars and he racism and vintage
races. Oh yeah. I've seen that. I've seen videos of it. Yeah. So that,
that's pretty cool. Yeah, that is pretty cool. You have,
what year is your gt? Three it's a 2007 okay.
That is maybe the greatest car, like the gt three
in the argument, the greatest car mate.
It's a very exciting car to drive. It's a thrilling,
fun car to drive. It's super lightweight and mind's a shark works car.
So it's got 518 horsepower.
There's a place called speed Vegas.
It's a track outside of Vegas. You go there and you pay, you can drive whatever,
you know they have like Ferrari's and landlords and stuff.
So I've been there a few times and the last time I went they had the new gt
three with the rear wheel steer. Oh yeah. And I was like,
what if this is God's own sports car? It's like the handling,
you think it and it does it and the whole time you're driving it,
the car's laughing at you. Like I'm so much better than you are
in half electronic nanny shit. The new ones have.
But the new ones are quite a bit faster and the new one is the,
the gt three touring is the shit because it doesn't have all the crazy fins.
It's because he, most of the time you're not driving and on track.
He just driving it around town.
So you get all the feel of a gt three but you don't ha it's more stealth.
It looks almost like a regular nine 11 yeah, they look man,
they have barely deviated from their style since like the 19 fucking sixties I
am such a fan of the nine 11 it's, it's my favorite car.
I've had a few nine eleven's of all the cars I've had, the,
the one I regret was the 88 turbo. I regret getting rid of that.
I'll always regret having gotten rid of that. That call was, it was a beast.
It was hard as car, but, but when it was going, it was like perfect, you know?
And those cars there so tail happy. Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah. It was,
it was trying to kill you all the time. The call was literally like,
if you get scared and let off the gas, I'm going to kill you. And that boost,
you know what I liked about it, it was motorcycle fast.
It was this crazy motorcycle,
kind of like just high rpm and then the boosts would kick in and the rear end
would snap and you'd just be flying like you better be pointed in the right
direction, you know? Have you driven a Tesla yet? Yes. He'd driven the,
the fast one. The p 100 no, I haven't driven that one.
I've driven the, I guess it's the regular [inaudible].
I drove one with ludicrous mode though. So maybe that is a,
people get to experience that. So fastest thing I've ever driven in my life.
Yeah. That's zero to 60 in like 2.4. 2.4. Yeah.
And then the roadster is going to come out. That's 1.9. Yeah.
You know that that was like when um, motorcycles went crazy with a horse.
I mean now their bikes would over 200 horsepower,
but when they first came out with like the higher bussas and stuff like that,
a friend who was a dealer and he said, you know,
you're going to be able to buy the rear half of these cars. He said like,
people just go to open the throttle and crashing and shit. You know, he's like,
it's like, yeah, you can get the clean back half of a higher booths or an Arwan.
When you sell a kid a high of Bussa,
what percentage of those kids wind up cripple or dead?
I'm not a high percentage, honestly, not out of laundry. Nothing. Maybe.
But I don't even know if it's that high because if you told jokes and one out of
a hundred people in the crowds heads exploded. Yeah.
Well you haven't been to my show. I really do that Joe. I get them.
I get so deep and cerebral. Then I throw in a Dick joke. Oh
No. You know the thing about, yeah, motorcycling is dangerous but
okay,
I know why more people die on Harleys and cruiser.
Sound like Neil degrasse Tyson right now. No,
I'm going to tell you the reason why is because they're the ones who they only
ride once in awhile and they go to a bar, right?
And they hang out in the afternoon drinking and then they get on their Harley
and go home. They don't wear a helmet and they crash and they die.
That happens more often than a kid racing around because you know he's a kid,
he's got quicker reflexes and in a real sport by guys are wearing the right
protective equipment cause it's part of the culture.
But unfortunately it happens. I was just at a motorcycle event last week.
I was doing a show and they do these rides and one of the guys died on,
you know, during the event and it was really sad.
But unfortunately that that's part of it. But whenever people hit me with them,
like yeah, people die in cars too.
Like that's the Neil degrasse Tyson side of it. Like yeah,
people die in cars too. And this is, this is what I choose to do. And I've,
I've managed the risk. We've talked about this, right. So you know,
my thing would would bikes is,
look if you live through your twenties you'll be fine.
Your twenties is when you're stupid when, but yeah, but,
but it would be the same thing.
Imagine if you had a gt three and you were 22 years old.
I had the odds of the fast cars when I was in my twenties I always spent all my
money on fast cars. Yeah. And, and you know,
the odds are against you on that too, you know, cause cause you do,
you do stupid shit and also don't know how to handle them correctly.
Don't know the, the limitations. You don't know how to turn or stop,
well you don't know when to turn off. Yeah. Yeah. Any you're like,
oh that was too late.
Know when you feel the tires break and you're still going straight and like,
yeah. Or you don't know the road you're on.
Like you've never been on this road before and suddenly you suddenly learned
what decreasing radius means. Yes.
It's just amazing how fast bikes are. And now they're making electric bikes.
Yeah. Don't have any shifting, which is very interesting to me.
Harley has a new bike. Carly's got an electric bike. The live wire.
No I haven't. I've written electric bike but I haven't written Harleys.
It's supposed to be stupid fast. Um, they, they all are. It's,
it's all just numbers. You know, it's just like cars, right?
Like how many cars now have a top speed of a hundred 5,080 and most or whatever.
But it's just the number. But cause you're, you're not going to get there.
Right. So it just becomes that even, even the zero to 60, you know yet.
Well with the Tesla,
you could do it cause you just step on the gas would step on the accelerator and
do it. But most cars yet it can go that quick.
But you can't cause you're not that good a driver, you know, so you,
you and it's the same thing with bikes.
So bikes can be super quick but you're not skilled enough to do it.
Like we laugh about it all the time. That's it right there. Yeah.
That's the hardest. Oh look at that thing.
What is that crazy shit between your legs up the batteries? Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
That's the batteries cause of all small. What a fucking beautiful bike. Yeah.
What kind of um, range you think these things have?
The one I rode had like uh, 80 mile.
I have no idea what the Harley miles,
well it can't carry big batteries like right.
I have no idea what the range of 110 mile range. Yeah.
Interesting city dwelling consult, consumer travels in traffic frequently.
110 mile ranges were realistic. Okay. So,
so cut that down because 70 yeah cause you're going to be opening it up every
chance you get balls. Batteries will recharge from zero to 80% in 40 minutes.
That's pretty good. That's using a stage street supercharger connection.
That's another thing with electric cars and electric bikes,
they're going to have to standardize this charging. You know,
cause it's like okay so Tesla uses one charger.
Then like Audi uses a different one. Now Harley's gonna be like,
you're going to have to come up with some one size fits all so that you can just
plug your car in and charge it. You can't have each company having their own.
Well you have a universal ones at the airport and the airport.
I plugged my car into the airport this past weekend. Yeah.
And that's the first time I've ever done it. I was like Ooh,
I found a spot electric and I a yeah,
just a little adapter you put on their universal one and it plugs into the
Tesla. Okay, well that charge charge while I was gone and got their full charge.
That'll work then. Yeah. Cause that's what I was thinking. Cause you know,
cause I heard like Porsche's developing a network of charges,
which I imagined Porsche and Audi, you're going to use the same one.
You're right. If you have a Tesla supercharger, can you plug a portion into it?
I don't think so. That's stupid. Yeah, they good.
They gonna have to figure that out. Yeah, that's weird.
Where are they going to be? Like apple, you know,
like you only use a lightning cable. You can't use a use USB-C.
I'm an apple guy. The domino where apple. This, this is where I drew the line.
So I uh, I got the iPad right?
And then I got an iPad mini and then I wanted to get the pencil.
Do you notice a separate pencil for the mini iPad and irregular? I was like, no.
I was like, no, it's a really, yeah. Why exactly. I was like,
are you kidding?
So you want me to spend 99 bucks for each one of these pencils and then figure
out which one is which. Right then I can't, what if I accidentally had it was,
it was ridiculous. It's like, come on, do way worse than that.
There's a website that I follow. There's a youtube channel rather than, I follow
what's the guy who repairs computers and he was talking about how apple goes out
of their way to make things so that they can't be repaired from developing
proprietary screws that other people don't have a screwdriver for,
to literally having motherboards where you cannot replace a piece,
it's not not possible. So this piece goes bad.
They have to replace the entire motherboard. And he's like,
that is so irresponsible. Yeah. And he's like,
the only reason why this exists is because people allow apple to do it.
He's like any other company, whether it's IBM or over Lenovo or fucking Dell.
When you buy a laptop from them you, there's all these parts,
you could bring it into a place they can replace this or replace that.
And here's the chip and here's the that. And it's easy.
But with apple they make it so it's difficult. Third party only apple. Yeah.
Third Party people. They don't want anyone messing with it. Fucking gross, man.
Yeah, it's gross. You know? And then the lightening seed, the seed cable,
the lightning bolt a thing versus USBC lightning bolt is not as good.
It's not as good. The bandwidth's not as fast.
It doesn't transfer data or power as quickly.
That's another thing.
The cable thing is something like every time you get a new gadget,
you got another cable.
Yeah.
Well if they just went with USBC USB standing USB secret android phone,
every fucking one of them uses USBC. Yeah,
because you, the fact that you have to carry a different k and then you're like,
does this fit that and then you know, then yeah, it's pain in the ass. Only
thing that apple has gone forward is privacy in terms of phones.
They are way better with their privacy,
but because of that privacy and protecting your privacy,
that's also why apple maps suck.
Like apple maps is not nearly as good as Google maps because Google maps is
following you to the bathroom and they're sending all that shit to Cupertino or
where the hell they are. They, they, they get all the data, all of it.
Everything from ways from this, from that. That's also why it works so well,
you know,
but their text messages and all the different things is not as secure as I
message I message is all scrambled and encrypted and could well,
and the other thing would, apple is, you know,
for someone who's not a techie or whatever, it's the integration,
the seamless integration between the apple products. Oh, including your, um,
if you have, I, what is it? ITV? What is it? Apple TV.
If you have apple TV you can like type shit up in your phone.
Your phone syncs out, your phone syncs to your TV and your Ramon as a keyboard.
Yeah. That's your remote. Yeah. Every and,
and you don't have to know how to do it. Like it says, Oh, I'm talking to blog.
Like, like you put the password in on your phone, then you open up your, your,
um, iPad and it gets the password from the phone and it's already connected to,
you know, whatever networking, stuff like that.
So you're getting better at that though.
They're getting closer and closer to filling the gap.
I mean the new Samsung phones are as good,
if not better than anything Apple's ever put out. Yeah. The thing is,
are you in the apple ecosystem? That's all it is. Yeah. Which one?
Which one is your normal? Yes. Which one is, are you used to it?
And as a hilarious bit about it,
here's a hilarious bit about being both Vegan and android.
Most a person could ever get discriminated against. It's fucking hilarious.
It's really funny that little, the little dots,
like if someone's, like if I send you a text message,
you applying and you start replying, I see the dot, dot, dot. And then it stops.
It's like what's going on? What happened?
You just use ghosted me and just pull me off.
You were gonna reply it and you're like, can you change?
But like with the green message fits an android.
You don't know when it's coming. You don't know. I've got that message.
Part of me likes that better.
Like I don't necessarily want you to know I read your message and it used to,
I used to get reflux when they know you read it. Yeah.
Cause now they know you're intentionally not answering me. Well.
That's those little dot, dot, dot. Yes. Those little dot, dot.
Dots are ratting you out. Yeah, that's what Ian says. Oh No.
Need everyone to know that I read your message, man.
That dude is so funny.
He's hilarious and I'm so happy he finally has a comedy central special fine.
Yeah. You talk about overdue. He's so good. You know who's knacks? Owen Smith.
Yeah, he's a mother fan on.
Me and Owen were talking and we were talking about the business side cause he
was talking about the whole writers thing about writers giving up their agents
and this and that and that. And he was, he's so smart on it. But yeah,
Owen's hilarious. One of the best comics on the planet earth. Yeah.
People don't know. Great writer and great performer too. Yeah.
He's so funny man. I've been working with him a lot lately. Oh yeah. Yeah man.
We did a lot of gigs together. Especially like a providence store.
He's as good as anybody. Yeah, definitely. And people don't know. Definitely.
Hey, listen,
the last thing I need is people publicized in another tall black car
when Smith who publicizing finally got an appreciate it show. No,
it, it's, it's great.
But that is funny that there's a kid named Andre Leclerc out of New York.
Funny Guy. He did new faces last year and my manager, uh,
signed him and I was like, you know, you know,
it's over when you manage your son's a younger, better looking version of you.
Like that's the last thing I needed was,
but he's a funny kid and that's not a good benefit to being good looking in
comedy. No. If you want to do sitcoms but they don't really exist.
Say if you want to do,
if you want to get into movies and do like a Romcom thing.
I think it comes like that was what Montreal was all about.
He got a development deal and you did sitcoms. Yeah. Now you, um,
well now it's streaming services and um,
movies I, it's still, movies are still like a different animal.
That's a different breed. I have zero desire but streaming services and uh,
you know, it's really funny too, because people talk about acting like I get it.
I'm not an actor and I'm okay with not being an actor.
I like hosting stuff. Like if, and I like unscripted TV and stuff like that,
but, but you know, when p like, would you want to show? Well yeah,
of course I'd want to show. I mean, it's, you know,
ton of money and this and that,
but the actual doing it and creating it,
like my mind has never worked like that. You know what I mean? Like,
like some people,
they love playing characters and stuff like that and all due respect to that,
but it's not what I do. But people are almost like, well, why don't you,
and it's like, cause it's not my thing. I have a joke about that. Yeah. Yeah.
The comedy is the only thing where they ask you to do something else once you do
it right. Yeah. Yeah. If you're a cook, they never ask you, do you farm,
you know? Yeah.
But it was always the way that everybody got famous. Right.
[inaudible] and Seinfeld and Tim Allen and all those guys,
they got sitcoms based off and stand up and then they basically became actors.
But you look at the numbers, you know,
there's a hell of a lot of comics for every one of them that made it to that.
You know what I mean? Like overwhelming. There's, you know, and um,
but for some guys that was like,
the thing that drove him crazy is that they never got that call.
Like Richard Jenny, he was, you know,
I remember I saw Jenny in Montreal and uh,
at the comedy works murdering God. He was funny. I mean,
he was a beast on stage. These people, I mean,
you could see his specials and you kind of get it,
but if you saw him in real life, you'd be like, fuck yeah,
he's the one of the most forgotten GM salute.
He was a brilliant standup. So good. I saw him, fuck.
Speaking of what she was talking about, a corvette,
a salesman trying to sell him on options on a corvette.
And he was talking about that in Montreal at, at the comedy works.
I remember sitting in the back of the room and I remember knowing that he was
bummed out because he couldn't get a sitcom. He had that one. Platypus man.
Yeah. And he was in the mask and platypus. Man.
The HBO special was wanted a great one hour she go ever see, have like,
if you can find it, it's one of the great one hours of comedy. He was a monster,
but he was one of those guys that really wanted a special, or excuse me,
really wanted a television show. Really wanting to show,
I wanted to be validated. You know who I am. I never understood,
never got a show. I mean he's had shows but didn't have a sitcom. Dumb,
dumb or rural. Yeah. Cause he's such a natural character.
When he was honestly a con with Damon for awhile for, yeah.
I think for like half a season and he had the sports show on comedy central.
Right, right, right. That was funny. The football show. But,
but it just seems like he was such a natural character, just being dumb. Like,
you know, nobody gives a fuck less than dom Irrera. God. That's true.
That's what he said. And he goes, he goes,
I wish I was gay just so I can come out of the closet.
That's how little I give a fuck. Say it.
I wish I was gay. Sarah would tell you I'm gay. That you know,
fucking hilarious. I love watching him. I love watching George Wallace.
So those guys are just masters of the art. Yes. Yup.
Just go on stage and just kill it effortlessly because it seems like George
Wallace is back in Vegas, is that correct? Yeah, he went back last year.
I do the road for a bit and he's like, ah, no. He, I think it was one of those,
I think they made an offer, made him an offer he couldn't refuse.
I think it was one of those deals. He's got that great following in veins.
I mean he always was things that people would go and they were on vacation in
Vegas. They would go to see George George. Absolutely.
There was like Rita Rudner had that carrot top hat that there's not a whole lot
of residents in Vegas these days. Not Anymore. Not like,
not on that level where you're aware of it, like carrot top lawyers be there.
But it's a tricky one. Cause if you commit to that, you give up all that, the,
the road momentum, you know? Well you gotta be able to market it.
I mean that's where George was brilliant.
George figured out just what you said for people to go home and tell their
friends, hey, when you go to Vegas you gotta see George was like,
he figured that out and that translates on the road and no, no,
you got to, uh, I mean, again,
you have to figure out how to build that and it takes time to build.
It doesn't build right away. So you gotta be working with a place.
So working with a producer or somebody who's like, yeah,
we're going to spend a year building you as a destination show and you have to
be willing to live in Vegas. Yeah. That's like, you're,
you're, you're almost, you just in some weird purgatory.
If you can handle it, it's okay but it, but if you got advice,
if you have any advice, Vegas is going to find it and destroy you with it.
You know? Oh there's gambling or pussy or I just worked with Mau.
Mau had this great Choco in Vegas.
He said Vegas is the only city you can watch someone become homeless.
You can watch them at the table. You just watch them. Yeah. Like your,
your whole life is falling apart right now. Yeah, I know.
But this next role they will let you mortgage your fucking house.
Absolutely. Like, yeah.
What do you want to do and on the role of a dicer hand of cards,
what do you want to do?
Vegas is the only gig where they will pay you in advance. Yes.
Pay the first night. Yeah. Want it. Here's some money. Yeah, here you go.
Tomorrow. Thanks. That fact. I don't know if you win too much.
They stop you from coming back. [inaudible] like Dana white from the UFC.
He gets banned cause he's really good at blackjack.
So he'll win like $1 million in a night and they banned him from casino cause
they know who he is but they're banned him cause he's winning. Yeah.
Like what is this fucking what you only play if you win you piece of shit.
It's their game. But that's their house. But that's a ridiculous rule.
They should, they should have to go under they shit. They all, you know it's,
it's like their rules and they, they're all in it together.
But that seems like rejecting service, you know.
I mean it just seems like they shouldn't be able to do that.
And then what's the sign?
You always see we reserve the right to refuse service to anyone. Yeah. Right.
So where do you work when you do Vegas? I do.
Brad Garrett took the MGM, that's a great spot. It grew.
Loved that room and I just did Kimmel's new club. I heard that's great.
Too beautiful as well. That the Rio, no, it took the link.
It's that where that big Ferris wheel is.
They opened like that midway strip. It's on there.
Sometimes the Rio too is not a new one. The seller. Oh, that's, yeah,
the sellers at the Rio. That's great too.
I heard that's what to Vegas has like they have the laugh factory now.
It's comedies made like part of wide. When George left,
he said one of the things was like for a long time there weren't that many
comedy shows. He said then suddenly every place had a comedy show.
So that cuts into the ticket sale. That make sense?
The Mirage is the shit. That's my favorites yet. I fucking loved that room.
I used to do bigger rooms and I even if I would sell out the bigger room,
I'd be like, fucking Mirage. Yeah. It's so good. So now I just do the Mirage.
I'm there all the time. It's from where I'm standing. It's quality situations.
It's the best man. It's like you. I was watching, um,
one time Joey Diaz was on stage and I was in the back of the room and in the
back of the room at the Mirage. It was cool.
Crystal clear sound that that works for comedy rooms. Right.
You gotta be able to hear him and see him. Yeah.
You know somebody, I forget who it was, but this, um, it was a musician.
He said the best room is when you can see everyone's eyes.
[inaudible] cause he had done like big rock concerts and all that.
And he was like, yeah, if you can see everyone's eyes, you got a good room.
That's the ice house heights or like you said, comedy works,
places like that where you can,
you can actually connect with everybody in there.
The ice houses stuff to fuck with.
That might be the best the ice ever created room.
We used to say, if you bomb,
you should be allowed to go to the ice house the next day just to get your
confidence back. Right. Just cause like, Oh man,
I don't know if like you could do it, man, go to the ice house, you can do it.
And then you walk out like, yeah, I can do this. You know,
there's agents that won't accept tips from the ice house cause it's just too
easier with them. It's cause it's, you do great. Yeah, definitely. Yeah.
I saw this great comedy. Magic is, is pretty God damn good. Yeah.
Comedy magic is like, and you know Mike and Richard,
they're so nice to you tonight. It's just like confuses you. Stop.
Cause now, cause now you've ruined people for anywhere else, you know,
food. Oh
steak that you could get at a fucking steak house when I had broken my wrist,
right. And now I was living in studio city and this was in her most a beach.
So to your listeners, that's 30 miles apart in la traffic,
hour and half hour at least. Right.
Mike was like, you know, if you, if you want,
we can send a server to bring food to your house. Like if you can't like Mike,
I live in [inaudible]. He's like, yeah, I know. And he would've done it.
You know, it's like are you kidding me? Like
[inaudible] store in 2007 he reached out to my agent and said we would love if
Joe could work at the comedy Magic Club. We support him.
We'd never hired joke thieves. And you know,
when we know that this is going down with him,
we would love for him to come here. Like, he's that nice of a guy. Yeah. He's,
he's a, he's a super nice guy and, and Richard the manager,
Richard still goes places to see comics to see if they, you know,
good for the club. Yeah. That's like nobody does that anymore. Like you,
you, you got video trickles down the top, you know,
the love and respect of the comedians and then just to be treating performers
well. Yeah. And that's why all the old pros still work there. You know.
That's why, you know, Ray Romano was all that. Like they still go there.
Leno's still there every Sunday cause it's like yeah,
he still goes every Sunday, every Sunday. That is crazy.
Cause I kind of stopped for a while when he was not doing the tonight show on
him. Yeah, he took a break. But yeah, he's still pretty regular there on Sunday.
I haven't not seen him on stage. Do stand up ever. I have,
I've only seen him on television. As a matter of fact,
we did a benefit together last year and it was fun watching him work like as the
comic, you know, cause he was doing, he was doing bits and all that,
but he'll still tell a joke.
But like he's a really good joke teller so he'll tell just a regular joke.
But it's hilarious cause it's so good. And then, and uh,
in Montreal I just did a gala and Howie Mandel hosted and it was so much fun
watching how we be a comic again, how he was doing.
He was cracking on the crowd like during the commercials, like what are,
you know, during the breaks he was just, and I was like, man, it's,
you could see that he was having fun, be in a comic,
not being a TV guy, not being a g t guy. Just, yeah,
I'm just being a standup comic and Gig is a great gig.
I'm sure he gets paid a lot of money,
but if you go back and listen to how he man down in the eighties and the
nineties when he was just doing standing up, he was fucking brilliant. Yeah.
He was brilliant. A lot of those guys, you know,
and and women with those comics,
people don't realize how great a comic they had to be to get that job.
They're like, ah, he just does that. It's like, yeah, dude,
our Cineo is like that.
Like I've seen people who see Arsenio do stand up and it's like, well yeah,
there was a reason he got the show. They didn't just say, hey man,
that's a funny name. Like Arsenio's a beast when he does stand up,
Taylor knows one of the weirdest cases, right,
because he doesn't have a body of work. Well, because he never recorded it.
He said he would never record it because then you sell it,
then you can't do it anymore. And they said so he would just,
but yet he wrote jokes every week for the tonight show. Like, Hey, Jay,
put your shit out there buddy. I mean, people don't know. But then again,
you know, what did he lose? You know what I mean? It's like he didn't,
he certainly didn't need the money. I don't think James ever like, man,
I should've sold merge. You know,
people knowing how good he is, I would think. Yeah,
I think the people would want to know he was,
I guess he's comfortable where he's at, you know, and, and people do well.
And also, you know, if you do go see him live, that is great that you,
you get to see him and you get to enjoy it.
Nobody wears a Jean shirt unless they're comfortable. You gotta be,
you have to be not wear it everyday. No. God Damn you got a uniform. Yeah,
he does. Listen, Alonzo, I gotta wrap this up. All right.
You got an Amazon special. It's out. What? What's the day?
It's out August 23rd. So heavy, lightweight. Today's the sixth. Uh,
let me know. We'll tweet it. We'll let everybody know. Absolutely.
And a heavy lightweight on Amazon prime and Amazon prime streaming on your
phone. You can get it on everything. Get it on, you know, you know something.
You go to whole foods and just watch it. No, I'm kidding.
But what the hell owns it, right? Yeah. He owns it. No,
thanks for coming in brother. I appreciate it. Thank you Jo. Fear,
not the new podcast that's out there too. Man, I love you, honestly.
I love you too. This is so great. Thank you. And again,
thanks for the love you gave me. Even when I'm not your man,
you know I love you. And we're working tonight. Yes. Improv ton improv tonight.